good
evening and welcome to this meeting of
the planning committee and welcome to
those watching
online if the firearm is fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs please do not use the lifts
please assemble in Hy Square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise you when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber does anyone intend
to film the
meeting I would advise that speakers
using the microphones are picked up by
the cameras recording the meeting
members of the public in the public
Gallery behind the speakers may be
picked up by those cameras and have
their images captured any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to move or leave the
meeting would everyone present please
ensure their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive calls or messages in the
chamber whilst this meeting is in
progress I have the following the
following members who wish to speak
under Council procedure rule
20.1 item ao2 councilor right items A2
and d10 councelor Smith item R9
councelor Curry and items 4 d and 4E
councelor Davis would any other members
who wish to speak under Council
procedure rule 20.1 please announce it
now thank you the following applications
have been reserved for public speaking
item 4 a 221 Beacon Road broadstairs
item 4B who Farm 147 monton Road items
4D and 4E which both relate to the
former Port control East Pier
Ramsgate item 4 I 223 to 227 North down
Road Margate item 4 J land between 47
and 49 rose gardens Minster Ramsgate and
item 4K land to the north of Fair Lawn
Road and the west of Northwood Road
broadstairs I don't have any apologies
at the moment can I just check that is
still the
case no and uh I have a declaration of
Interest councilor ran item uh 4 k no
sorry uh
4f thank
you we will come to the procedure for
that when when we get to that
item um do members agree that minutes of
the planning committee meeting held on
the 18 18 of October be approved as a
correct record can I have a proposal
please councilor bayford and second de
by Council Orbin do members agree agree
thank you um just a reminder any site
visits will take place for committee
members on the morning of Friday the 1st
of
December so uh moving on to public
speaking uh first item
a1221 Beacon Road speaking against the
application I have first Mr Steve
Nicholson you have three
minutes
um I'm Steve um I live at
223 um one half of the semi in question
the application is for a loft conversion
in itself unextraordinary many people do
it we have no issues if that was all
that it was however it's also an
application for a second story extension
onto the rearward projecting part of the
property the top of this um
extension was designed to be lower than
the eaves of the main house and when you
enter any room in it you will step down
into the room um this enabled it to be
lower than the eaves um this because
these extensions were never intended to
overshadow or infringe their own garden
neighboring Gardens or neighboring
properties and that's
us an additional story on top of this
will be a huge impact on our day-to-day
life as it overshadows the entirety of
our property at the rear the only way to
maintain it uh will be from the roof of
our side of the uh of the extension our
ground floor dining room and our first
floor office will be kept in permanent
Shadow so in our opinion it's at odds
with the original design of the house
it's out of character with every other
Loft extension in the street it
overshadows our garden overshadows our
study and our dining room the side wall
can only be maintained and accessed from
the top of our roof most of the houses
that face back into the square formed by
all the gardens are Victorian builds of
the same or very similar age and design
and although many have Loft conversions
not one of them has built a second story
on the rear facing extension so this
would be entirely out of place with the
character and appearance of the garden
scene but it is the infringement of the
use and enjoyment of our garden our
dining room and our study that we feel
is the biggest impact of the Second
Story extension so we oppose it thank
you thank you uh can I just get you to
turn your microphone off please thank
you um the principal planning officer
Emma will now outline the
report thank you chair uh this is the
application site here outlining red so
this is Beacon road you can see the um
area here with the dark shading is the
proposed extension
um this is the aerial view of the site
so again um it's uh this property here
so you can see that the area to the rear
um is surrounded by property so there's
no um external views of the rear of
these
properties and then another uh view of
the property so this is the property on
the left hand side here with the Red Dot
above it so it's a pair of 70 attached
properties that's a twostory in height
and you can see at the rear there's a um
a rear projection into the garden um
given its traditional um historic uh
design uh this is taken from the rear so
the rear elevation of the existing
building so again the application
property is on the right hand side here
and the adjoining property on the left
is um the property of um uh the neighbor
that we've just heard speak um so you
can see from this view um that the
garden of the property the application
property itself is smaller so the
neighboring property wrapped around to
the rear of um their
property and then this is some photos
from the rear looking towards it so the
application site is on the right hand
side here so again the right hand side
of this pair of semis um you can see in
terms of looking around at neighboring
properties that there's quite a few
Dormer windows that already exist um
this is a a closer view of it so you can
see again the neighbor has a Vu window
high up within the roof space and the
windows being referred to are um where
there's concern regarding light is is
this window here which um the neighbor
has confirmed is a study
window
and then again this is just some views
of some neighboring properties so again
the application properties on the right
hand side of this photo and again you
can see a number of neighboring
properties have all extended um into the
roof with dormal
Windows and then again to the other side
the application properties on the left
hand side of this screen and again you
can just see some of the existing
properties there's fewer um Dormer
extensions along the right hand side
here then just a view from the front so
again the application properties on the
left hand side here so the proposal will
involve um the hip to Gable extension at
roofless level with some vux windows
within the front um roof slope the
original application did include a
dormal window at the front but the
application has been amended to remove
the Dorma so it is now solely for and
vux is in the front roof slope and then
again just a view of the front there so
these the existing elevations on the
left hand side um you can see the
existing um front elevation and rear
elevation and this is the proposal so
the the left hand side again is the
front elevation you can see the hip to
gabed extension with the two vux windows
within the roof slide
and on the right hand side you can see
the proposed rear um ex elevation so
what's proposed is a Dorma wind flat
roof Dorma window within the roof space
with some French doors and balconet and
then this is a second floor extension
that um extends above the rear
projection um that already exists so
this line here is the existing roof
slope and you can see this is a full um
depth um flat roof extension above above
that
element uh this is the existing side um
uh um elevation so again this is the
existing projection that comes out from
these properties and then this is The
Proposal with the extension above um
that rear projection and the dmal window
in the roof
space and then this this is the other
side um proposed um elevation so again
you can see the dmal window and then
this element here is the proposed
extension and here you can see the
neighboring um Pitch roof above their
rear
projection uh this is existing floor
plan
the so ground floor level is not
changing um first floor level this is
the existing rear projection and then
this is the RO existing roof so the main
change is this Central um floor plan
here where you can see the extension
coming out at second floor level to
create an on Suite um uh provision on
Suite above the existing rear projection
and this area here is the dmal window
with the French doors and balconet which
would create a bedroom Within in the
roof
space so the the concern from um the
neighbors regarding the impact on light
to their their windows so as you can see
from this this photo the um the
extension would extend in this area here
so in terms of the impact on the
neighbor neighbor's Windows there's a
distance of 3 m from the side elevation
of the rear extension to the side of um
their window and so 3.3 m to the central
point of their window in terms of
Outlook you can see that there existing
rear projection already extends beyond
their window and causes a loss of Outlet
to that window so the only real issue is
is whether there's significant harm from
from loss of light to that window to
Warrant a refusal of the
application um the neighboring property
is um Southwest of the property so there
will be some loss of light from this
extension at roof level um but uh given
the distance and and the location of
this it's not considered that it's not
going to have a significant impact on
light and as you saw from some previous
photos there's already loss of light
again from the existing rear projection
on that window um the vux window is
quite high up within the roof space
there's not been any confirmation of
what this what room this window serves
it's it's not clear whether this is a
habitable room um it may well be uh Loft
space I'm not sure but um again because
this is quite high up within the roof
space and it's um angled it's not going
to have much Outlook or uh from that
window already so the the creation of a
an extension above this space is not
considered to result in significant harm
to to the Outlook or or light into that
window um these are some this is a photo
that the neighbor has submitted as part
of their objection so just so you can
see the impact from their vux window and
the impact of it again the extension
would be in this location here um
extending up along the central parit um
so if you were looking right out of the
window there probably would be some
Outlook lot of Outlook but again if
being the height of the window um within
the the SP the roof space and the fact
it's got quite High seal you wouldn't
expect to have normal um loss of lighter
Outlook from inside that room looking
out so it's considered that the impact
on the neighbor is is unbalanced
acceptable and in terms of the character
of the area given the fact it's on the
rear of the property and is surrounded
as you can see from this photo by
existing properties and there's no real
views in whilst it is um not
particularly characteristic of What's um
around there in terms of the fact
there's no other properties that have
extended at this level it's not
considered there's a justification to
actually refuse it on the visual impact
of it given the fact there's limited
views from outside um private Gardens in
this location so it's recommended for
approval thank
you thank you and um I move that the
officer's recommendation is adopted
would the vice chair please second
seconded thank you and uh who would like
to speak councelor
bright thank you chair um yes I'm on the
planning committee at Broad stair Town
Council where this application was
recommended for refusal based on the
impact on the neighbor um after
listening to the officers report um I
still don't think that um the loss of
light and loss of privacy have been
suitably addressed um it's and it seems
to me like it is a a very large
extension um and I do wonder whether um
I mean there's nothing else like it
along along that that row and I do worry
that this is going to be impacting
significant significantly on the
neighbors so therefore I was wondering
whether it would be possible to request
a site visit thank
you thank you councelor
Kean thank you I'm also concerned about
the loss of light for the neighbor so I
would um you know be in support of a
site
visit
thank you councelor matterface you chair
as ward council I did call this in for
exactly the same reasons that a councel
as brigh has mentioned there are no
other properties along that stretch with
anything other than a simple Doral
window and I feel because of the way
those Gardens are the G that those
houses face East West so the gardens
going north south I think a large part
of the light onto the rear Garden of
223 will certainly the sun would
certainly um not get into the bulk of
their Garden um the speaker did mention
loss of light to habitable room
including the dining room and the study
and I would have thought that would have
been sufficient cause for concern to
maybe give this some
consideration um a site visit has been
proposed and I would like to see if that
could be could be voted
on thank you councelor Wing uh I won't
go over lot of light thank you chair but
is there any chance we could go back to
the rear view of the whole run of houses
because although you said there's Dorma
type uh Dorma type developments there I
couldn't see a Dorma type roof that
comes out over a projection so this
would be a first incident of actually
creating something that actually goes
beyond the roof the roof
area uh so I think for me that's a bit
too far uh it it it's it's it's it it
detracts from the character that we've
already got and there are some Dormers
but there aren't Dormers that project
out the back and also has there been any
consideration about the extra runoff the
neighbor will get if the rain is driving
in a certain direction up against that
sheer wall that they're going to have uh
I I don't know whether there's any
indication of extra Plumbing that that
would take that water back round to the
person who's built the the extension or
not but it is a considerable problem
when you live in a house that's got
higher walls either side of you I live
in such a property and water runoff is a
real problem when you've got rain
hitting the larger building to one side
of you so yeah I I I would support a
site visit to get a better understanding
of it but for me that extra bit sticking
out is just a an extension too far thank
you thank you councelor
Albin thank you chair um
I I have to say that the extension the
Second Story extension is is uh rather
odd it doesn't fit in with the rear
elevation of the property at all in in
my humble opinion um I I don't see a
need for a site visit um you could see
the impact that this is going to have on
the next door property and I think if
the uh applicant were to come back with
a different
application uh for another another uh
Second Story extension that fits in with
uh the property um then that would be a
lot better I mean it stands at the
moment or it doesn't stand at the moment
as it happens chair but um uh I I can't
support this application thank you
chair councilor matterface if I could
just come back it's been mentioned um
the three the three properties on the
left with the two Doral windows they're
they're new they they were in Phill a
few years ago so they are actually very
modern and one of them does have um a
loft extension which she put in in the
photograph at the back of the property
if you could bring that back the the the
bit that you can see on the back is
actually the bathroom because those
houses were built without bathrooms so
what is seen sort of directly above the
red card there they are actually
bathrooms on the first floor um but as
councelor Alin said this is going to be
an extra floor above that which is SL I
would consider slightly out of balance
with the rest of the houses
there thank you councelor
Mak can we see the orientation somewhere
please so to see where I can see a
shadow but
see how much light gets
to those
windows so is that North
South
yeah so the front of the house faces
Southeast is that
right
I think it faces
Southwest
sorry this yes this is correct in terms
of the orientation so the um extension
is in this location here so um so
Southwest of the neighbors's rear
projection
so oh councelor mo thank
you yes good evening chairman thank you
could I just ask Mr Livingston that this
application doesn't contravene any
planning uh criteria at the moment
therefore if the committee were of a
mind to try and refuse this and this
went to appeal there's a good chance
that the applicant could win
that um so the the two main issues that
have been raised so far one is a
character and appearance point which is
a matter of judgment that members could
exhibit something different from
officers um I think from our perspective
The View that you're seeing is from that
parking area that you can see in the
image that's there obviously that is
used limitedly in terms of by people you
in the wider public realm uh our main
concerns with the dorm windows at the
front which were removed is because
everyone would see them and they're B of
character so there is a judgment about
even though um this is clearly an
extension that is different from any
other extension there because it's on
top of a structure it's effectively a
second floor uh with the dmal windows
mostly found at the rear it's not got a
lot of visibility so our concern would
be that would be something that ins ECT
would take into account um in terms of
the relationship with the neighboring
property again a relevant very relevant
consideration in terms of whether or not
there is a loss of light or sense of
enclosure caused again our judgment is
because of the distance that's there
even though the orientation means that
there will be an impact on light because
the neighbors sort of to the northeast
of this this extension because of that
Gap that's there um it's not considered
that that would be sufficient from our
perspective to
you know refuse the application but it's
not to say it wouldn't be unreasonable
to make a different decision from that
if there was a consideration it would be
the sort of thing that I think would be
if if the motion to approve were to fall
I think it would be beneficial for
members to visit the site if they were
going to look to refuse it on the impact
on the neighbor um to councilor orban's
point the impact on the character and
appearance of the area you can really
make a judgment I would argue from what
you can see and this image in particular
particular about how much you would be
able to cease from that specific parking
area as opposed to from The Wider public
realm can I add my own question which
links into to councilor's more permitted
development
rights what is the situation regarding
permited development rights um so the
extension on top of the um ation um is
is the element which definitely needs
planning permission um I don't think we
have a calculation in terms of the hip
to Gable and then the Doral window on
its own uh subject to a few provisors it
would I would anticipate they would be
able to do a roof extension without
needing planning permission but it
wouldn't be the design that you can see
it's that that second floor extension is
the bit that triggers the need for the
application do I have any other
questions or
comments uh I mean i' I'd like to
support councilor alurn suggestion that
that if we're of a mind to refuse this
we're actually just suggesting to the
the applicant that they need to think
again and maybe scale back which is you
know something a lot of people have to
do when they submit planning
applications they have to go away and
think again or choose to appeal so so
you know we we're batting the ball back
in their court if you like because we
have some concerns in in certain
areas thank you C
bford thank you chair yeah I mean I
think I agree with what most people have
said um I'm torn because I feel that the
distances mentioned uh with the hand
probably would render it acceptable but
it cannot be denied that it does look
out of place with other other properties
I can't really see the point of a site
visit I can't see what that would tell
us so I think personally I think
probably go straight refusal in the hope
that they'll come back with something
more acceptable thank
you okay any other questions or comments
no in that case uh we will now put the
motion for the officer's recommendation
for approval to the vote could I have
those in favor
please and those
against the motion is lost um just bear
with us a
moment oh sorry did the ab abstentions 1
2 3 4 5 thank you apologies for
that um thank you chair um so obviously
we've heard the the different points um
and and the points of concern so the the
options for members in terms of anyone
wanting to propose a motion would be one
to go for a site visit or if a member
wants to propose a motion for refusal on
particular grounds um then if that were
to be the case then I think it would be
worth doing an adjournment but it just
depends on what members want to do and
who wants to get the chair's attention
first really Council Auburn yeah sorry
chair um yeah I propose refusal of this
application um happy to come and talk to
the uh to Mr Livingstone on the reasons
why um if he feels that would be the
best way forward um but certainly uh I I
think the the Second Story extension is
bulky uh I think it's out of character
with the rest of the with with the house
and um and there are I must admit I do
go slightly along with what councelor
bayford has said about the loss of light
I think uh there's already loss of light
there through the current are it
currently sits um but uh I think we
could include that in there as well um
um so that would be the basis that I
would um be looking at unless Mr livon
has got any other comments chair thank
you just bear with us a
moment
all right just going to bring Mr
Livingston back in for a moment thank
you chair um so just to go through those
points specifically before a member may
wish to second that and then then put
that to the vote so in terms of the
development being out of character due
to it scale and bulk specifically so the
the policy is is qd2 the local PLS that
character appearance the area so that
that reason would be one that that you
know would be sort of elaborated on but
those tenants are quite core in the in
the motion that's fine just on the point
with regards to the loss of light um I
think just to clarify the reasons need
to stand on their own so there would be
two separate reasons they both need to
be
justifiable um in terms of that reason
if it was a concern that there would be
a loss of light to the neighboring
property which would result in
significant harm to their living
conditions then again that is a matter
of judgment obviously but it needs to be
I just wanted to frame in a slightly
different way rather than the adding it
on it needs to stand on its own and
members need to be aware that they will
be judged independently it will not be
done as one thing because it's a
different policies that's qo3 of the
local plan um so if if Council always
Happ to put that the motion on those two
grounds then it' be about a second I'm
happy with that actually thank you okay
do I have a second for Council orban's
motions councelor bright okay before I
go to the vote on that we have had four
people mention that they would like a
site visit if you want a site visit you
have to vote against councelor Alban's
motion and then we will go to another
motion that would be to have a site
visit I'm very aware that there are a
number of counselors that haven't spoken
and indicated if they actually want a
site visit um so
just to remind it's a straight refusal
um under the conditions that we've said
um who would agree with
that put me on that
one okay that's carried um but who was
do you want the against yeah we'll have
the against anyone against and any
extensions three thank you yeah that's
Carri so that motion is now carried
thank you
okay ready for the next one right moving
on to the next item which is item A2 who
Farm 147 monton Road Minster um for
initially we have speaking under
councelor rule 20.1 councelor
Wright thank you
chair okay
um this application um
was it was originally taken in
2020 it included the provision of us a
usable pedestrian connection to the
footway in Monon Road this is described
as a critical requirement to the
sustainability of the development a
drawing um there is a drawing which is
reference
20119 strike 35
01 was submitted for
an the for an effective 1.2 footway with
a condition to be put in place to be
completed before the the construction
began it was the responsibility of the
applicant to seek consent and leat with
KCC KCC has confirmed that this has not
not happened however the footpath has
been rushed through causing much anger
to the res the area due to the ripping
out of an established head HED row and
loss of habitats to provide access
between to developments on on the land
with uncertain ownerships um in
September 23
theant have made no attempt to comply
with the grant of consent for the larm
or obtain any changes during that past
the past four years until now but what
what they want but what but want the
planning committee and the planners to
agree to what has no rec
recom relevance to what was applied for
and ignoring the fact that TDC
enforcement have commenced action for
non-compliance in May KCC have since
made a quote made a quote the idea of
installing four sets of gates and use
them at your risk is ridiculous finally
with no certainty of the future upkeep
of of this unauthorized footpath and the
impact of the obstructive and
encroaching vegetation
which goes against which therefore I
believe this goes against the local plan
the application should be refused
and the and the enforcement
recommendations the applicant required
to comply with the condition conditions
18 and subsequently there's another one
condition two this request to refuse is
also supported by Minster Parish Council
thank
you thank you uh second also speaking
under count uh Council rule 20.1
councelor Smith at 3 minutes thank you
do we stand no all right don't like you
that much um at the risk of repeating
some of councelor rights um
statements this the promised footway is
a critical requirement to the who Farm
Redevelopment sustainability the
developer appalled local residents by
tearing up many yards of prized hedge
row and increasingly rare hedge row um
to construct a footpath in the wrong
location and to inferior standards it is
not acceptable that for 4 years after
the original planning application it
cannot guarantee safe and secure passage
for
pedestrians
residents are Village
residents are accustomed to walking
along Monon road which links Monon to
Minster it is a narrow and potentially
dangerous road to pedestrians traffic
has increased
marketly uh due to developments in the
in recent years and this develop M will
increase it further if it becomes a
private footway which appears to be the
trajectory the developments residents
will inherit responsibility for its
upkeep and that will be much harder to
enforce Mina's population has a high
proportion of retired people and the
risk of injury should not be ignored in
order to save the developer money and
trouble at your own risk signs transfer
liability from The Constructor to the
pedestrian but it does nothing to
mitigate the risk of
injury uh KCC highways commented that a
footpath between the site and the
existing footway on Mon m road has been
constructed or be it without entering a
section 278 agreement with KCC highways
having visited the site it is evident
that the foot path is not constructed to
adoptable standards due to its alignment
M and
levels this planned
feature was originally subject to a
grampion condition so should have been
completed as per the approved plans
before construction began whereas the
show home opened to the public last
weekend with no such feature in
place the developer claimed that it
could not construct the approved
footpath because it wasn't sure who
owned the
embankment um to this I would reply that
there well a that there is a clear
procedure for establishing ownership and
for overriding if unclaimed and B the
very same embankment was flattened to
create Farm access just a few meters
along the
road after complaints from local
residents TDC planning enforcement
officer informs the development that
they were not compliant in May May
2023 since then rather than finish the
project to an acceptable standard or
remediate the problem so LLY done the
developer has sought retrospective
permission to proceed as is my
conjecture is that the at home planning
consultancy allowed the developer to
believe that this inferior offering
would be granted permission
retrospectively I just hope that the
planning committee will prove them wrong
thank
you the thank you the principal planning
officer Annabelle will now outline the
report sorry
apologies apologies chair um this is the
applications I outlined in red um and
this is who Farm the development that
was approved in 2020 sits in this
location
here so this is Google image of the site
so that the development would be the
residential development that's been
referred to and approved in 2020 sits in
this location here and a footpath
would um runs along here to join the
existing foot paath that exists towards
Minster um as has been set out in the
report and in speaker um presentations
planning permission was granted in 2020
for the construction of 23 drillings in
this area
here um for the construction of sorry 2
F rings so the after the demolition of
existing buildings in this location and
this permission did include the
provision of a 0.9 M wide footpath to
provide an Eastern link from that
residential development to the existing
footpath heading towards um Minster
there on that same side of the
road um this plan is from the the well
2019 application which was approved in
2020 and the footpath proposed was to
run along between points X and Y on this
plan um this is also the plan from the
2020 application and it shows the layout
of that footpath so it would be at that
time was proposed to run alongside a
Monon
Road and be 0.9 M
wide um but following the grant of that
consent the applicants found that there
was insufficient Highway Verge to create
the footpath in that location and and
some of the land required was in fact
unregistered so the applicant has
created a footpath which is 1.2 M wide
which does connect the residential
development which is as members May well
know is actually under construction
currently to the existing footpath for
most of its length is actually set back
2 m from the road and it is at a higher
level for some of it um than the highway
I'll just show you some photographs um
that actually taken today of the
footpath So This Is Where It Starts Here
this is the access into the development
and this is where the footpath that's
been created starts um so we're walking
along obviously heading down towards
Minster so you get an idea of the foot
paath and you get some idea that it is
um slightly higher here than the Monon
Road another view um some members can
see it is
surfaced um but I mean you can see as
well as you can move further along there
are some instances where it does it's
not a straight foot path it does Bend
and there are some changes in levels as
you go along not necessarily significant
changes in level but it isn't even and
flat and that's a Viewpoint where it
does join the existing foot paath
that uh there and you can see the
changing level as you walk down towards
that foot path and you can also see
there that it is higher than the
Mountain
Road so this is the planers it's curing
it ex the footpath that's currently
being built out there is a tiny bit
missing cuz it start you can just see it
there it doesn't go all on this plan it
doesn't completely show it going to the
access this is the farm access that's
been mentioned that's
constructed and it you as members can
see as you walk down it it does veryy
slightly in sort of bend a bit and as
you you've seen from the photographs it
does vary in height and step down to it
and as has been mentioned it's set
further away from monton road than was
originally um approved in the 2020
application
so this is the proposed plan U which um
would be the finished footpath that's
being proposed by the developers there
would be four Gates um put in so one as
you enter this is the actual entrance we
saw in the photographs to the
development there'd be a gate here into
the footpath and Gates either side of
the farm axis and there will be a
further gate um where it joins the
existing
footpath
um and there would be signage on those
Gates that actually talk about the fact
that it is not an adopted footpath by
for casc but would give contact details
of the ownership and details for people
to contact
to
um deal uh do with them but it also will
set out that it is a public footpath and
the gates will not be locked so it is
available for everyone to use the
footpath and just to give you an idea
this is the sort of gate that's been
proposed so it is a sort of traditional
gate you might find in the country side
and as mentioned they wouldn't be gate
uh locked or chained in any way
they would but they would need to be
pushed open it is really just to Define
that that is not normal casc adopted
footpath payment
Network so as has been mentioned um casc
highways have stated that due to its
alignment and changes in levels that
they would not adopt the footpath as
part of their network but they do not
object to it to consent being granted
for the proposal subject to conditions
that have been set out in the
report and it is considered that with
the changes in level and alignment and
the gates um you know having to be
pushed and opened and
closed that it it doesn't resemble a
traditional sort of foot pavement you
would see just adjacent to a road and it
probably has more of appearance of a
sort of public right of way which might
have styles or Gates and things like
that but it is considered not to be a
problem in terms of character and
appearance because you theyve given its
Countryside
location it there is no adverse impact
on residential amenities from on
surrounding occupiers from the foot path
or its Gates and signage that were
proposed and whilst it is accepted that
some users may find the footpath
difficult to access and use given the
gates and changes in
levels um but many users will be able to
use the foot paath as alternative to
walking in the highway it will be
publicly available and officers do
consider there are sufficient safeguards
in the conditions that are going to be
imposed if members were to Grant the
consent for maintenance Etc and the
footpath to be kept clear of
vegetation and so the officer
recommendation is for approval thank
you thank you um I move that the
officer's recommend ation is adopted
would the vice chair please second
seconded thank you we will now debate it
do I Haven I've got loads of hands so I
saw councelor Kean first thank you thank
you I mean the look of the foot path to
me looked fine but I think the gates are
a big problem we should be thinking
about accessibility and I'm not sure how
accessible it is for someone in a
wheelchair for a mom pushing a buggy if
you've got to open and close Gates along
it so I'm I'm concerned about that I
presume that what was originally
proposed didn't have Gates is that
correct that is correct yes thank you so
as I say that to me is the main
problem councelor
driver
thanks if we say no to it's a a a
question actually I if we say no what
happens uh do they demolish it or build
a new one that was my question thank
you um thank you chair um so if the
application is refused then obviously
the um the applicant has the ability to
appeal the decision um if it's uh
obviously it's not appealed indeed as
soon as the decision is made and if it
was to be refused then it it basically
passes back to enforcement um and then
um obviously members being concerned as
they are um then we would look to um
potentially then serve a notice to
basically return the land to its
previous state because the development
that's here that they've done that
requires planning permission is the
laying of a hard surface there is a
related application but it is
independent application which is in with
the council at the moment which is to
vary the conditions on that original
planning permission to remove the
requirement for the footpath in its
previous
location so obviously one decision could
knock on to the other in terms of what
we do with that um it's obviously
difficult to predict whether or not
someone would appeal a refusal obviously
in this instance though um it it would I
think it I would sort of bet on that
occurring I think that's fair to say um
given the fact that this would you know
require um it sort of affects two
different things it's not just the
development that's happened it's also
then the fact that you still need to
provide a footpath for that residential
development so there there are a couple
of knock-ons that would happen in that
event councilor matterface um can you
tell me what is the difference between a
footway and a footpath or are they the
same terms because in the document it
refers to footway but on the drawing it
says foot paath and this is a public
footp paath which uh traditionally is
own is maintained by the owner of the
land anyway
so the people who would be living in the
property would have to maintain it if
they want to keep it as private land is
that correct uh no so the foot the foot
footway
footpath um interchangeable in this in
this aspect it doesn't it's not defining
anything particular so um a couple of
the conditions that are proposed pick up
some of the bits that you raised about
maintenance and I do appreciate this is
a concern about actually something going
on to the residents that that that that
could you know that that puts an
inference that they need to do something
on that so the conditions that we put on
are are effectively to ensure that um
the conditions need to be compliant with
by the owner of the land in this
instance obviously there's an an
ownership element that has changed to
allow for the footpath to be constructed
um and the conditions would be
enforceable against the owner of the
land rather than in this instance the
residents for for example um maintenance
is one thing that's that's covered in
this condition I think is it three or
three um and and as well as that there's
the added point in that condition about
making sure that the footpath is open
and kept available for use um the
condition which is before that is um
removing permitted development rights
because there's a quirk of the system
that could mean that you could put a
gate up which is locked without needing
consent under that which is why we're
taking away that permitted development
right just in case um the point of the
conditions is to follow up from the
highways comments um and this is It's
whilst obviously the I appreciate the
concerns that highways are raising are
kind of covering the point that they're
not adopting this and therefore people
need to be aware that you know they
aren't the responsible body for the
maintenance of
it the point here is that we need a
footpath to connect this residential
development um and that this application
needs to be considered on its own merits
I think you know certainly the planning
Department's view is if we were making a
decision between one or the other there
was a reason why we granted it in one
place but that's not the Judgment that
we have to make and that's not the
Judgment for members it's not an either
or it's a is this acceptable as it is on
its own merits thank you
chair yeah um the gates which are going
to be like country Gates it it four
Gates on a path that's that not that
long I mean it does seem a bit of
Overkill I mean I do lots of country
walking you be unusual to have a gate on
a foot path like that that's not sort of
a farmer's field type of
thing um if if I may come back on that
the um the the reason why there are four
Gates there's one at the one at each end
but it's that you can see the two there
it's because of that farm access so it's
a a safety point that the two that are
there are to delineate the access
directly onto the farm arm for vehicles
there's another one that's offshot to
the um to the to the right of the image
or the the the east of the image
yeah okay I have councelor Mo
next yes thank you chair um so the
original application was a an 0.9 M
pathway and the developers given us a
1.2 M pathway which is obviously wider
um some of the objections was saying
that the it's uneven is that um uneven
because of the way that the Contours are
and it's tarmacked or is it just it's
poorly laid um and are we really just
objecting or are the objectors objecting
just the fact that the foot path has
Gates on it um and that there's no
ownership they're the criteria questions
I think thank
you I'll sorry I'll carry I'll carry on
thank you ch um the um in terms of The
Contours um there is obviously there has
been a change to the Contours of the
land I I don't think it's we're not in a
position to say whether or not it's been
done in a particular way because of just
the Contours um although there is a
clearly that land is not was not level
originally so um you know and there is
deviation because of the length of it um
there is deviation along there's it's a
there's an element of up and down there
is also an element of side to side as
you move to the actual access points
when it goes to that Farmer's uh gate
access um so there there is that change
um I think in terms of the objections
that have been made have raised a number
of points and I think a number of
concerns about that this is um you know
from residents perspective far from
ideal I think in comparison to what was
originally required by the planning
application um the application has
submitted the reasoning behind why this
has transpired um but
again um I think that that's for context
but it's still again in its own way it
still needs to be looked at on the basis
of the merits of what's been proposed
rather than again that either or and why
they say they couldn't do what they've
done because of unregistered land um you
know it just needs to be looked at on it
on its own basis um the gates are a
point of objection um but I think there
are numerous points of objection that
have been
raised councelor bayford
thank you chair the first question's
been answered about the purpose of the
gates um but I mean I I feel it's not
unreasonable for a
country uh footpath to be slightly
uneven um it's very strange question but
how unsafe would it be to actually walk
along the road for example for a
wheelchair or somewhere is it a very
busy road is it is it unsafe to do
that yes
I think I think there are there's a
reason why there's a need for a footpath
between the Housing Development that's
there obviously there are properties in
and around who farm at the moment which
are all you know which are which which
have been in place for a number of years
and obviously didn't have footpath
connection uh but obviously specifically
one of the requirements of us having
approving the Housing Development was to
ensure that we were trying to provide
safe pedestrian access
Council
Garner thank you so just to recap on
this application this is it so we got a
developer who sought permission to build
houses and after much to and them throw
in between KCC highways between planning
officers I bought an application to
planning committee in May
2020 which was approved with a number of
conditions one including to create this
a certain type of footpath in a certain
place along the side of that road it
seems a
developer has off his own off their own
bat ignored that condition and decided
to build a footpath somewhere else in a
different place uh which resulted among
other things in loss of hedro and I
think that's without consultation with
the planning Authority
um this led to a number of residents in
the local area complaining about it and
enforcement were persuaded to get
involved then so the developers now
submitted a retrospective application in
the hope that this planning committee
now will just ignore the previous
planning committee's um approval and
conditions they made and let them get
away with it let them do what they want
to do rather than what they were
conditioned to do and I don't think
that's good enough and I don't think we
can be seen to be just what is the point
of passing planning applications with
serious conditions in them that we want
developers um to to to do if they can
then just ignore it and then come back
to us and say we've ignored it we've
done what we wanted to do now we want
you to give us permission to do
something differently I don't think we
should do that and I
after listening to what others have been
saying I will be voting to refuse
permission for
this thanks chair just to come back on
on a point there um in terms of I I keep
saying the same thing about considering
the merits of each proposal the fact
that it's a retrospective application
cannot be taken into account as as I
know that members are aware it needs to
be still looked at as if it hadn't
happened um even though
um in this instance obviously there is
the background of that application and
the specific requirements of the
condition um I mentioned earlier about
obviously the rationale that's been
stated in this is in the uh in the
report about um the the the perspective
of the develop about the unregistered
land and not actually constituting
Highway Verge to be able to then provide
the footpath as per the condition um so
that is their perspective on how things
have have come about um again in terms
of the actual proposal in front of
members the question is whether or not
actually there are grounds to refuse
this application and in that instance we
looked obviously to KCC highways in this
instance to to give us uh you know their
steer on um pedestrian safety even if
they're not adopting it they are still
the statutary highway Authority and we
look to advise on that they have
obviously given their comment which is
in the report they've suggested that
there would need to be conditions to
make it acceptable and that is obviously
what we have have moved on but so the
judgment is about whether or not what's
been done is safe not whether or not
what's been done is um as ideal as the
previous uh previous approval thank
you
I okay one point because the it is about
whether or not it's safe now I did hear
I
think um Annabelle might have said that
actually it wasn't considered to be
totally so
and she I think she I mean correct me if
I'm wrong but I think you said there
were cases where this wouldn't be safe
for some people because of the
undulations that are now in the foot
par um well it's the opinion that some
users might find it slightly difficult
if moving Gates and but I don't think
it's I don't think so much the
undulation is that extreme that it would
cause most people walk being able able
bodied people to walk along it quite
easily in the same way you might walk
along a footpath it's nowhere near as
undulating or unlevel as many public
foot paaths going it it is more it's a
sort of nearly level but not completely
level and it does slightly turn and
we've seen in the photographs where it
drops down slightly but it's it's
gradual level changes it's not
extreme but it would is considered safer
than walking along the highway for most
people would be able to use
it I've got councelor Wing next I'm
still I'm still confused with the whole
gate situation could you go back to the
picture the the the real picture of the
lovely
path the other one that looks down it so
if and I've got lots of questions to ask
so if I am i' i' actually like the Bendy
bit with the lampost so the first
question I want to ask is where is the
unregistered land because I'd like to
see see what which bit of land made them
move I'd also could you go to the the
lamp post close to the lamp post cuz I
think obviously the lamp post is a
problem so if I'm coming off at the end
of this will I see a gate and if I see a
gate surely I can just walk around it if
there's a gate at one end and the other
so the function of the gate is
absolutely useless if that if that
footpath isn't enclosed by another fence
I'd also like to know have we got a hump
situation so we've got a rise going up
and a rise going down I'd actually like
to know the gradient of that of of that
rise up and Rise down and whether it's
compliant with the equalities act and
and and disability access because
looking at the gradient there I
certainly know that my 86y old mother
would not be able to go down that slope
safely in her electric wheelchair we've
spoken about people going onto the road
but how do people in wheelchairs get
onto the road when there is no dropped
curb
so I
cannot uh I cannot approve this because
I cannot sit here as an able-bodied
person and approve something which is go
going to be
unsafe for people with mobility issues
and we are in Minster where there will
be a significant number of older people
with mobility issues there's just you
know that then this it's also unadopted
and we know as Ward counselors when you
come to an alley which is unadopted
it's very difficult to get rubbish
shifted from it foot paaths mended holes
in it mended because nobody wants to
stump up so the the other issue is who
does the land belong to that that
footpath is on top of and are they aware
of this and the other issue is do we
want to set up a situation for our I
think it's our one and a half
Enforcement Officers to have to keep an
eye on a on a short piece of pathway
that really should be compliant with the
with with modern standards of foot
paaths and certainly compliant with KCC
so I can't support this
either um so to just come back on a
couple of those points um because you
ask some questions with regards to um
what's being proposed so I mean just if
looking at this image here the the
unregistered land um from what we
understand effectively the edge of the
highway um that you can see where the
current foot path on the right hand side
of the image is at the moment or uh and
that was to obviously to continue on
along with the road basically so you're
right on that line of Road you you can
see along with the mouse pointer there
um so that is the unregistered bit of
land that grass bit that you can see
there is effectively the unregistered
land so it originally thought to be
Highway Verge which means that KCC
effectively have control over it and
then then you can um you know do it that
way and actually go through the highway
act to get the foot path in but again
what's been put forward is that that
wasn't um that wasn't possible given
that it was unregistered um in terms of
the um the point with regards to
accessibility um obviously the provision
of gates uh does make it more difficult
for different people to um access that
footpath um in terms of your point about
people being able to walk around it um I
I yeah I understand what you're saying
there obviously um that's not to say
that it's always going to be quite as
clear in terms of that Verge as POS as
it was in terms of the bits outside of
that site sorry outside of that foot
paath um but that's that's true there is
a there is a particular reason obviously
why highways have asked for that uh gate
so that people are aware that they're
going on someone else's land that's not
highways um in terms of gradients we
don't have that information obviously
this is one of those situations where
it's it's there so we don't have we're
not we're not really able to actually
request plans to show the gradients it's
literally a judgment that can be made by
again officers visiting the site and in
this instance obviously KCC highways
again looking at this site and seeing
what's actually been done on site as
well um I i' take your point with
regards to the whether or not you're
restricting access with regards to um uh
I suppose less able people um I think
that there is a there is a provisor
within the mppf which talks about trying
to provide safe and accessible
uh pedestrian links in this instance
there is clearly a balance to be struck
between what developments this is
serving what it's connecting to uh and
in this instance obviously we've put
forward a recommendation that we should
approve it because it does provide a
wider foot path um you know that does
allow for uh the vast majority of access
um as for specifically electronic
wheelchairs or I suppose um Scooters or
the the buggies that you get Mobility
AIDS um
it it's it's I'm afraid we're not
qualified to say that that's
definitively able to be used I would say
from walking that myself uh there are
bits where the gradient is is more
pronounced um you can actually see one
in this photo here um
but it I it's very challenging for me to
State definitely it's it's a gradient
but it's not a severe gradient I would
say on that the only way to judge it is
to walk it I'm
afraid
I have councelor Kean and then I do have
councelor Orin and councelor matterface
and thank you I mean it's the gates I
know Kent highways have have said they
were needed but it's the gates that
bother me in terms of access and I can't
see why I could you know I understand
the need to make it clear that it's not
um owned by KCC could there not just be
signs I know that's not the proposal
here but for me the gates are actually
hindrance and I can't see they make
anything
safer can I just confirm one thing um
there are signs as well sorry just to
confirm so it's it's it's it's both but
yes I tell you yeah absolutely councilor
alurn yeah thank you chair it's been
quite interesting listening to members
discussing this um I'm probably going to
be against most of the people who spoken
tonight um in that you you got a choice
your human being you you got a choice
you don't have to walk down there you
can walk in the road like they do now
and and uh disabled buggies whatever I I
take it they are they go along the road
or disabled people will go along the
road without using that I I'm just
taking that as red um so either you have
this or you don't right and then you're
going to have to put something something
else in but whether you can make them
take it up or not is another is another
matter and I've just had a couple of
questions first uh it's been mentioned
about the Hedge taken out was this a
protected hedge do we do we know
question please uh no so we when we
originally had reports when the when
this was removed um there's no
suggestion that was done in
contravention of any um you know it
wasn't unlawful the
removal okay so that's not a problem
might be a problem for for people cuz
the Hedge was nice etc etc but legally
it's not a problem two uh another
another point it's 1.2 M than when it
was going to be
0.9 what what we talking about this much
I mean that it's that's just nonsense uh
in in relation to the width of the the
foot the foot path
um personally speaking again I I concur
with colleagues are saying about the
gates are not particularly I mean they
don't have to put them in they can be on
the plan but they don't have to they
don't have to put them in unless a
condition says that they have to um so
that's up to them whether they whether
they put the gate the gates in can I
just check with the officers is there is
the condition says these Gates must be
there uh yeah condition two within two
months the gates and signage have to be
in okay okay so so that so that's a
condition we've got to deal with this
application not the previous one that's
being taken care of of enforcement are
taken care of that and they can continue
with that um personally I can't see
anything wrong with it I can't see why
you would refuse it I really really
can't so I won't be refusing this year
thank
you okay um
can I also wanted to ask did the
developers by any chance look at
registering the unregistered
land I I I I can't speak I can't speak
to that I don't know I'm afraid I could
have okay do I have any other speakers
in that case I'm actually going to ask
another question Council Wing It KCC
have managed to put a lamp post in the
unregistered land how did they do
that I I I I I think actually to be
honest it may be this is you know this
is without this is you know without
knowledge prely that actually that may
actually delineate where the
unregistered strip is uh between that
post and the footpath but I I can't I
can't speak to it I I don't know I
haven't got the details of when KCC put
it in uh and and yeah uh so I'm afraid
we don't have that
information and I've
heard almost everyone that's spoken has
talked about Gat do we really have to
have them because if I was walking down
that footpath i' just walk Round it
um so in this instance we've we've we've
applied to put the condition with
requiring the gates on on the basis of
the highways commment so we've we've
looked to provide what they have
requested uh from their purposes to
ensure that in their mind that the
development is as safe as it could be uh
and that's why we think the gates uh
should be
included
councelor Wing I mean my concern is
still the gradient unless any of of us
have actually been in a wheelchair and I
haven't but I have tried to manage my
mother in a wheelchair which isn't an
easy feat on any of our foot paths but
this is a new foot path so it should be
the highest we could possibly do if we
were of a mind to to to disapprove this
or not to support it could they flatten
it out because it seems to me this
developer's got just a sort of Machinery
to level this out to to remove that
gradient completely to make it uh to try
and do all they can to get around a
problem that they have then there would
be like you know it's still unadopted
which creates a real issue for me
because going forward I can see this
just being a piece of foot path that is
never looked after if we're really being
honest but then most of our foot paths
are not looked after anyway so anyway I
just ask
that
um as to I think it's it's difficult to
say what could be done uh because
obviously in terms of actually
Excavating out basically underneath
where that path is at the moment um
obviously there are level changes either
side how that can be constructed again
it comes back to that point
of whether or not the proposal is
acceptable or not uh I think it's
difficult to start talking about what
then happens next in terms of how they
deal with the refused Al if it was to be
refused um and whether or not it's
adapting what's there or or moving
forward with something else I mean
clearly one way or another there needs
to be a foot path link from one end to
this Housing Development so whatever
happens whether or not you know this is
this is approved or or something else
comes forward um but um but yeah again
it's it's difficult to say exactly the
extent of work that would be needed you
can see there the level change that
occurs and the amount of excavation that
would be needed to get a level
entirely level all the way along um you
know from from one end to the
other councilor matterface um this is a
public foot paath this is not a
pavement so this is not the sort of
pavement you would get round tone so do
we assume there was slightly different
requirements if something's classed as a
public footpath as opposed to a pavement
that we would
consider because it's that what I mean
KCC didn't want to adopt it because
various things but if we class this as a
public footpath it doesn't have to meet
the same criteria as a pavement like say
out
there um so a a a path um as as part of
I suppose the highway act if you're
trying to adopt something under that it
does require to meet certain standards
and yet indeed that if it if it's not
built for that purpose it doesn't
necessarily have to meet those standards
um so in this instance obviously it's
not being considered under those
standards there's no requirement for it
to be ad adopted uh and indeed we have
you know many housing developments where
the roads aren't adopted um with varying
degrees of success it's fair to say um
but no in this instance it doesn't
necessarily have to meet a specific
standard under the highway
act okay if I don't have any more
speakers then we will now put the oh
councilor so I'm really sorry I mean who
have thought a little path would create
this much interest but was there a foot
paath there
originally no
no okay and again I'm now going to put
the motion for the officer's
recommendation for approval to the vote
those in favor
and those
against I'm okay and
extensions okay there a is a heat
between favor and against
66 okay you have vote chair's casting
vote I voted
against which which means we have to
write another
motion can I come back
to um don't don't Applause yet it's not
guaranteed we have to write another
motion so the options for members are I
it's pretty clear it's visit the site um
and then come back next month to have a
a further discussion about it following
that site visit uh or if members do
consider that the um footpath as as
they've seen is considered to be unsafe
by virtue of um changes in levels or
provision of gates then that would be a
motion that would have to be put forward
I would recommend that before doing that
action that members visit the site but
that's that's my perspective obviously
members can put whatever motion they
wish for it um I think I'm not going to
take uh questions from the floor I'm
going to invite those who want to be a
part of of preparing the next motion to
come forward just to discuss
briefly
a vote for a site visit then okay propos
in a second yeah in that case um who's
going to propose site site visit chair
and second councilor matter face in that
case all in favor of a site visit I
think that's
carried
got were there any votes
against and
then and any obss on that okay so that
that carried thank you we've got a site
visit
okay so the next agenda item is item A4
the former Port control East Pier
Ramsgate speaking in favor of the
application is Mr Tera Smith you have
three
minutes
thank you um well my plan was to hold up
about the pictures of the existing uh of
the original artwork um but that's part
of the application uh thank you for
having me over and also thank you for um
the original approval for the same
artwork A couple of years ago just to
explain why we're back where we are now
um the site uh underneath the brazer um
has deteriorated further it was already
going to be a fairly problematic uh site
to work with and to install the artwork
but um my conversations with the uh
Harbor Master have revealed that it's
actually a quite um poor State now so um
that was why the proposal to put the um
artwork back in its original location in
birth one was put forward it was outside
of the red line of the original
application which was approved so that's
why we are um we're here today so uh one
of the reasons for the um redirection as
well as the condition of the original
site was also it's the site that we've
already worked with we understand the
logistics and it's significantly cheaper
to put it into the original location
than to deal with the um treacherous
site um underneath the brazer so there
are practical reasons why it actually um
is quite a prudent decision to move it
back to birth one um also uh I was going
to show you a material sample of um um
copper the new material will be um
copper faced letters and that is because
it's a very traditional Marine material
and will um age very beautifully and
this material samp I had had turned a
very lovely of copper verree color and
that will be the copper um the color of
the letters uh in the new version of the
artwork um
so that was really all I wanted to say
just it's a lot there a lot of very
practic IAL considerations as to why um
the new site is actually preferable the
logistics are known um the expense is
considerably less and actually it can be
seen better from both East and West
cliffs in
Ramsgate thank
you thank you and I have speaking
against councelor Davis you have three
minutes uh thank you chair um firstly
let me explain I'm not against the
principle of art or or or or indeed the
uh the recognition of perugian miseris
which is let's remember been above the
door of the Lighthouse for the last 100
years so this simply repeats what we've
already got on the end of the West Pier
however my concerns are more about the
Practical or for this section although
we will come to the the listing aspects
in a moment or in the next item however
under 4D we're talking about practical
planning considerations this Council has
set aside 282 and half th000 for East
Pier building structural improvements we
have set aside 70,000 to replace the
ladders on this section of the pier and
the protective buffers are the side of
them the rationale behind that is to
enable larger vessels to dock on this
section of the pier on that basis why
are we spend and we have to spend that
by the way I'd like to highlight the
fact that whilst this has been installed
or another version of this because it's
not the same size as the previous
version that was installed these letters
are smaller than the ones that were
there before this is a listed at but
I'll come back to the listed asset on
the on the appropriate um
4E uh however we have set aside money to
use this pier as a working Harbor for
the purposes it's intended for it's not
a playground it's not a an uh a canvas
it's a working Harbor and we've got
enough issues with other areas of it
that are not being allowed to function
in their intended form
um the harbor listing incidentally I'd
like to remind members has been upgraded
since this last since this was installed
before or another version of the same
thing the harbor has been upgraded from
two star uh sorry from grade two to
grade two star listing which is quite an
important Improvement or enhancement to
the protection and it means that unless
good public gain can be sh there should
be no damage or anything to this to the
to the material of the the fabric of the
harbor I'd like to draw the the
committee's attention to the fact that
both the conservation officer and others
have said I would cons and the uh report
officer they consider there to be a
level of harm caused to the setting and
appearance that's the context of it
there is damage this needs fixing into
um the material of the Sandstone that
the peer built from which has got which
is having its own problems with
weathering anyway I don't think we
should be putting anything unnecessary
and a fixing it to the to the fabric of
the royal Harbor um and there are many
that think this the the the the
rationale behind allowing it would be
for social and economic benefits I'd
like to know what they are artwork is
great there are other locations around
the harbor that are quite Tatty that
these same letters could be installed on
and could still visible enjoyed by the
public and achieve the outcome um but
I'd sorry I will just finish um that uh
this is not the right location for this
it can't use the existing fixings cuz
the letters that are being proposed are
smaller than the ones that were fitted
there before it will interfere with the
use of the pier for the purposes it's
intended for and I'd like to point out
that it will need an MMO license because
it's below the median high water line so
there's a lot of questions before I
think this should be in any way
considered let alone approved and there
are better options thank you thank you
um I will now ask the principal planning
officer Annabelle to outline the
report uh thank you
chair so this application does seek
permission for the erection of artwork
signage on the East
Ramsgate um so this is the East Pier
here and this is the application site
outlined in
red and the site is in the Ramsgate
Conservation Area and has been as has
been mentioned it is a listed um
structure so just some photographs of
these
pier and one further zoomed
out so this is a detailed view of the S
of the proposed signage artwork that is
being proposed here as has been
mentioned they will be copper face
letters and they would be 1.2 m in
height and the actual meaning if if you
translate it from Latin I'm not going to
try and pronounce it is actually refuged
for those in
need and the letters would as as has
been mentioned as well be located below
high tide level so they would not be
visible at high tide level and there
would be a need for a license but that
would be a separate uh piece of
legislation for the applicants to seek
if consent is
granted um it is considered the proposed
develop sorry the poent would not have
any adverse impact on residential
amenity highway safety or flood risk but
there would be it is acknowledged some
harm for the physical attachment of the
sign to the listed pier and the
alterations to its appearance but it is
considered these are
limited and reversible
and the harm would be balanced um
against the social and economic Bel
benefits of the development and these
include tourism they include just the
the interest of the artwork
itself and it's the actual historic
regard to the maritime history of
Ramsgate and it is considered those that
that harm is not significant and is
outweighed by those other benefits of
this um proposal so it is recommended
for
approval thank you I move that the
officer's recommendation is adopted
would the vice chair please
second seconded thank you and I've got
councelor alurn first to
speak yeah thank you chair um I think
what's in interesting with this is that
when the previous artwork was there it
was very much welcomed by a lot of the
uh by a lot of the town and
visitors um and the important part for
for for me is seeing that the Harbor
Master states that the works have
previously been done and there were no
issues regarding it then so from ourside
there are no comments so the Harbor
Master has no issues with this
whatsoever um and he's the guy that I
would take notice of so uh all all in
all chair I I think this is most welcome
and I fully support it chair thank
you councilor
isaki thank you chair um actually I have
to disagree with my colleague there
because this is a listed grade two star
listed uh building that we're going to
start bashing about um to put up a sign
which could go elsewhere uh I don't see
the main advantage of putting it where
where they're proposing to put it
especially as half the time it's going
to be underwater um so what's the point
what's well what's the point of putting
it there then um quite GRE when the
water goes down to no no I'm sorry I
disagree with you there's no point in
having it there no one's going to come
and look at it if it's underw unless
you're gun
diving um I'm afraid this is a grade two
our listed building we shouldn't be
bashing it about we should be looking
and protecting uh these this this build
this this building um and if you want to
put a sign up put it up somewhere else
thank you Council living Council living
just you don't ever want that do you Mr
livingstone's just going to come in
thank you chair um just to clarify one
point the council re RI said there um so
this application is is a is a is full
planning consent so it's looking at the
setting of the list of building the
conservation era and the impact on the
conservation era the next application
which is going to be spoken about is is
the listed building consent so it's the
impact on the significance of the listed
Royal haror so that is the application
where the direct impact of actually
physically attaching this to the listed
structure should be considered it
doesn't mean that the setting of listed
structures of which the whole Harbor is
listed uh can't be considered when
looking at this application but just to
be specific about which application is
considering which
part councilor
rakan um I have to say that you know
with the minimal impact going to it's
going to have on the the harbor um I
think it I think it looks quite nice and
it's it's something different for brings
tourism so I can't see any harm so I'd
be supporting
it Council Wing it's obviously in my
Harbor in my world the harbor is in my W
sorry in sorry it's going to be a long
night but I I I fully support this I
know there are issues with the the
listed status if the harbor Master's got
no complaints then I've got no
complaints but I want to remind people
what the last insallation was like and I
was really unlucky cuz I didn't manage
to get one of the letters when it was up
for auction and the whole idea is that
is that it's revealed as the as the tide
goes up and down so there's a real
interface with the tide
that that sometimes you don't notice but
you do notice in the harbor there and I
think it's it's another thing that links
that will link another group of people
to the harbor which quite clearly is is
something that I think we're all rightly
proud of uh and all on all love uh so I
fully support this uh and the message is
is a good message as
well councelor Mo yes thank you chair um
as this is on the water line and and
that particular stretch of the AR but is
for larger shipping um how will that
signage be affected when larger shipping
are in there when the ladder ways are
repaired and larger ships are mored
there is it what what protects
it yeah it will be protected by the
fenders and we are obviously got the
haror Master's opinion that there would
not be an impact and he raises no
objection so we're assuming that he is
considering the harbor for larger
vehicle uh ships and as well as at the
current
time councelor Wing the last letters
were bigger they were much bigger and it
was a route that I often wore can look
at obviously uh because I live nearby
but uh the larger ships were able to mop
to to dock or more or birth or whatever
they do against the other letters so
clearly there is a way a maritime way of
uh of ships not being damaged and also
these not being
damaged and if this one is approved to
what extent is it dependent on the next
application immediately after this you
need both consents to be able to do it
is the easiest way to put that
anyone else in that case can I put this
one to the
vote uh no sorry I move that the
officer's recommend no hang on a minute
where have I got
to we're going to go to the V I was
right first time wasn't it sorry it's
it's going to be a long night um we'll
we'll now put the motion for the
officer's recommendation for approval to
vote those in
favor any
against and absten s and mine was in
favor okay 13 carried so that's carried
um so we're going to move on next to
item
4E um speaking against this is uh
councelor Davis again you have three
minutes thank you chair um I think some
of the points that need to be made here
have been made quite and uh councel
iseki has raised them I'd like to remind
the uh or recommend that everybody in
this room actually has a look at what
two grade two star listing means and and
and when it's justifiable to cause any
impact on a grade two last star listed
asset um there must be a clearly defined
public gain um and benefit in order for
that to take place um there is no yield
or gain with this other than yes people
like to look at it but they can look at
it perhaps at the other end of the peer
a fixed you know we've got ugly fencing
around the um slipways which has had
various proposals to put it on there
stick it on there it's still relevant it
still looks across the harbor we do not
need to drill into sandstone some of
which has got quite serious condition
problems we've got damage to that paer
caused
by apparently by the barge that was
mored there the Sandstone is of an age
it is not weathering well um also
despite the fact that there's no you
know the har Master by the way has made
no comment he hasn't said I don't object
he's said no comment now the depth of
these letters it seems comes out .17 M
beyond the buffers either side of the uh
ladders that I've mentioned for which a
budget of 7,000 has just been approved
in order to M ships there now if ships
are M there and we're hoping to have a
tool ships event in a couple of years
time so it'll be look amazing what's the
point in having it there if it's got
ships m in front of it because no one's
going to see it
plus the whole issue with the listed
Harbor is the fact that the listing was
increased it spread around the entire
Harbor estate and that was done for a
reason to protect it from further damage
this is not a playground it's a working
Harbor and for and and the rationale
behind this council's decision to spend
70,000 on the access ladders and the
buffers either side of them is firstly
because of the listed uh responsibility
but also as it clearly states in that
item to more larger vessels than we can
accommodate at the moment so I see no
point in approving some in in allowing
drilling into a a listed asset causing
potential damage it if it were to even
be using the previous fixings that might
be a different thing but these are 1.2 m
not 1.8 m High I'd also like to point
out incidentally that verdigre from the
distance across the harbor where you'll
see it against the Sandstone background
won't even show once it once it
deteriorates so you know however we're
talking about the listing and the
curtilage that view across the harbor
should be as it was designed to be as
smen and his predecessors did not our
version of
it thank
you thank you uh I now pass to the
principal planning officer Annabelle to
outline the
report right thank you chair I I will
skim through a couple of these slides
because we've just looked at very
similar
ones but I'll so if we're looking at the
sign it is correct that it would
measure the sign and its frame would
measure some 1.5 M High 22 M wide and it
would project as has been mentioned
0.17 M beyond the fenders on the face of
the pier and it would be connected to
the four Timber fenders one at each
end and two close to the center so as
you can sort of see in this picture
here um and they with four bolts in each
Fender and we would be bolted directly
to the face of the pier at Four Points
between between the timber
fenders so the physical attachment of
the sign to the pier would result in
some damage to the historic Fabric and
the pier
and the conservation officer has
commented
on this point and she states that she
does consider would be a level of harm
caused to the setting and appearance of
the listed asset and the Royal Harbor
but however all mitigations have been
made in the approach to the attachment
of the peer to the peer sorry and that
the physical harm is reduced where it
can be um she also goes on to say there
are areer public and social benefits to
consider as well as
um dis as well as the potential that um
the sign could be removed and the the
peer made
good
so sorry um so it's officers do not
consider the impact of the what don't
consider the sorry the harm to the list
structure to be
significant or Prejudice the future of
the listed structure
continuing and it is um whilst this is
an application for per permission there
is an indication that the sign could be
removed um what once it had served its
purpose if that was the case and the
structure made good has been mentioned
and it signage with with the same
wording has previously been installed in
a similar occation on the
pier and orbe it that the grading of the
harbor has been
elevated um after that time but it did
create a lot of public interest social
interaction and economic best benefits
potentially from you know increased
tourism to the harbor and Rams gting
General so it is considered that there
are public benefits that do outweigh the
limited harm to the to the list is
structure and the application is
recommended for
approval thank you thank you I move that
the officer's recommendations is adopted
with the vice chair please second
seconded thank you and I have uh Council
Mo and then councilor Alburn
next yes thank you chair um when this
sign is uh eventually installed um is
there a condition that is like um a
liability or Indemnity that should any
uh adverse damage be done to the harbor
that that's covered or is that not part
of
it um thank you chair um it wouldn't it
wouldn't be something that would be part
of any listed building consent so it's
separately in terms of any permission to
do anything to in this instance a
council structure um then um that's the
anything to do with damage is not
covered by planning law it be covered by
civil in the sense of um that would be
how any damage would be dealt
with councilor
alurn yeah thank you chair just to go
back on part of what uh councelor Davis
said um the my un my understanding of
the harbor Master's no comment is that
he's got no comment because he sees no
harm and that's why he's got no comment
um not or he might he doesn't um so
ditto to the last one I I fully support
it chair thank you councelor
iseki thank you chair I back to my last
comments really it's it's a great star
two a great two star listed uh structure
and we have to protect that that's what
we're here for um you wouldn't like it
if we went around starting uh sticking
aluminium Windows into grade two listed
buildings never mind grade two star
listed and what we're doing here is
sticking something on a grade two star
listed structure which it will damage
even though making it good with polyfill
afterwards is not going to not going to
actually do do any good to it it's a
solid Sandstone it needs protecting and
we're here to protect
it councelor Wing I don't think it's
going to be polyfill that will be used
but never mind and I don't think the
timber fenders smen's
originals and having lived in and had
the responsibility of protecting a grade
two listed building I believe it's more
about is there material change to a
listed structure and there clearly is no
removal of of uh of any important
features here there's just something
that is being added that can be totally
reversed uh if it's being fixed the wood
the timber the timber fenders then then
it it might not be fixed into the
Sandstone so I I fully support this CU I
think the gain the gain in terms of
tourist and interest in the port is it
outweighs the the the small the small
potential damage to to the listed
structure and can I ask about sorry I'm
I'm going to roll tonight can I ask
about the repairs to the wall um and the
impact
Also
regarding okay let's go start that
sentence again councelor Davis has has
said about the damage to the Sandstone
that's already there um how does that
compare now the condition now compared
to when this signage was there
previously have have we seen any
deterioration and has that been assessed
and how would repairs be carried
out um so we don't have any information
with regards to or or any concerns that
have been raised about the condition of
where this sign is to be installed the
um there is a separate application which
will be coming before members for uh the
area around the harbor brazer which is a
specific concern in terms of uh the
condition at that point in the harbor
but it's not with regards to this
particular this this stretch
specifically in terms of actually the
work that's to be done as as you can see
on the image um here um it's it's the
four holes that are being put um the
resin bolts that are being put into the
actual wall itself whereas all of the
other attachments uh are on the the the
timber um wall beam so it's it's a
limited incursion um as for how they
would be repaired it would it would be a
matter for um you know the well in this
instance the Harbor Master in terms of
requiring when it's actually removed
that it's made good um it that is
something that in itself wouldn't need
list to build and consent to repair or
fill in any holes but it would obviously
be under advisement of the actual owner
of the land which in this instance is
TDC do I have any other questions or
comments in that case um we will now put
the motion for the office's
recommendation for approval to vote
those in
favor and those
against it's carried thank
you right moving on
to item 4 I item
R9 103 sorry 223 to 227 North down Road
Margate
firstly um we're just going to I'm very
aware actually we've got uh quite a few
items left on the agenda um we're just
going to take a five minute break quter
to 9: we're going to be going on late
tonight so uh before we start on the
public speaking on the next one we just
take a 5 minute break thank
you
e
for
that's
all right if everyone could um move back
to their seats please thank
you all right thank you and welcome back
um so item R9
22 223 to 227 North down Road
um firstly for public speaking I have
councelor Curry under rule 20.1 you have
three
minutes thank you chair and good evening
members and officers um I'm here today
to support the retrospective planning
application for the International Food
Center in cliftonville for those of you
who are not familiar with the shop the
business has completely transformed a
rundown part of North down Road and
brought long-term empty units back into
use unfortunately the planning for the
building work was undertaken during the
covid pandemic and after speaking with
the owner it became clear to me that
during the second covid lockdown there
was certainly miscommunication between
the owner and his agent regarding what
had been submitted and agreed in the
original application I don't believe
there was any malicious intent by the
owner during the application process and
if it wasn't for the covid lockdowns and
the lack of imperson meetings during
that time I don't think we would be here
today the current shop front design was
is actually based on other nearby
businesses the shop front is impressive
and fits the need of a large modern
business which must be safe and secure
when both open and closed and offer good
Mobility access to all there are 40 or
so other aluminium Style Shop fronts on
North down Road however few are as
well-designed as the one now being
discussed a petition I saw online by
change UK raised by a customer regarding
this application gained over a thousand
signatur
in support from loc local residents
planning officers however do have a
difficult job complying with
Conservation Area regulations that just
don't meet the needs of many modern
businesses criminal damage suffered by
shops with the old Timber design has
fall some to close down due to high
maintenance and Rising Insurance costs
mainly due to large windows and front
doors that have been frequently
vandalized after reading the
conservation officer's report I checked
the north down Road conservation area
character appraisal and management plan
which can be found on the TDC website in
appendix 2 it lists all the historic
shop fronts in northdown Road and number
223 to 227 is not among
them the last thing we all want to see
is a new business which offers so much
to the local community incurring tens of
thousands of debt replacing a
state-of-the-art shop front with a
Timber design which is just not
practical for this type of business I
urge members to please approve this
retrospective application thank you
chair thank you I would um now pass to
the planning applications manager to
outline the report thank you chair um so
the application site is in the center of
the photo um this is an application as
mentioned for ret retrospective
application for the installation of a
shop front um the main consideration is
the impact on the Conservation Area
um so this is the site outlined in red
um so as mentioned um by councilor Curry
the site is within the Northtown Road
Conservation Area um the conservation
areas in around cliftonville were
designated in
2016 um and um as mentioned there is a
conservation area appraisal uh it
doesn't identify this um the the
previous shopf front here as as a
historic shop front um the prao hav also
talks about North down Road and its
entirety and identifies that one of the
main issues with North down Road and one
of the risks to the conservation area is
the erosion um of uh traditional
materials also the insertion of modern
materials and and quantifies that as a
negative feature of the conservation era
um so what we'll do is have a little
look at what previously was in situ uh
and what um is now in situe on the site
at the
moment so so this is an image from uh
2012 so it previously shows it when it
was a vacant unit um what you can also
see uh where the uh mopeds are at the
end you have a diff slightly differently
designed shop front it's a bit small I
apologize for that um but it's also very
similar to the timber shop front in
terms of a very small stall Riser and
large glazed openings with the fan
lights above but you can see how the
previous shop front was you've also got
um you can see here you have uh
aluminium doors which were present and
similarly there's an aluminium door here
and similarly then in the shop front
further along you've got an aluminium
door set within that uh that sort of
Timber work around it then this is 2018
um so obviously the the shop front is
still there but obviously it's no longer
got the glazing it's got the um
advertisements um that have been put up
the images that have been put up there
um you can see obviously then the
signage and you can see it's a a
different uh business at that point uh
to the right hand side uh within uh that
um that part of this
building uh and then we have a few
photos of the existing um shop front as
constructed so as mentioned the the
shopfront has been replaced with an
aluminium uh shop front um you have uh
this this side at the moment has
obviously got the the shutters down in
this image um and you've got the shutter
box which you can see running along just
underneath the faal sign see there's a
new entrance that's at the on the corner
uh which is now recessed whereas the
entrance was around the side and we can
look at the elevations to see that so
looking around then just to show you um
just a view as you go down North down
Road and then we've got a closer in view
so you can see it's now consistent all
the way across and there's another image
later on which shows this so um there is
more consistency that's been offered by
the shop front as it goes down um and
and takes in the other shop fronts that
are there there you go it's a bit more
of a a detailed View and then this is
the view from Google um so there is
history to this uh site it's it was it's
it's been an ongoing planning
enforcement matter for a while um
following the identification of the
breach we um advised that it was
unlikely that the aluminium shop front
would would gain consent in officers
view in relation to the um the the loss
of the Timber shop front and then we
approved a replace of the Timber shop
front um to go back however we did
receive a subsequent application for um
the retrospective retention of the shop
fun has constructed and that was refused
by officers on behalf of the council uh
this is the application that's now been
resubmitted and obviously it's been
called to committee for members to make
a judgment on in terms of the officer
view that hasn't hasn't changed
following the subsequent refusal um we
do have a loss of traditional materials
in this area um the previous shop front
was from uh I think it's between um 1907
and 1940 so it's not historic in the
sense of it's you know early 20th
century um but it does um contribute to
the it did sorry it did contribute to
the conservation area and so much as the
building itself was included in the
conservation area it's obviously down
the Eastern end of it um but it was
included whereas other parts have been
excluded from the conservation area um
the shutter box and style of the
aluminium shutters is of concern to
officers um in conservation areas we
would normally look for larger openings
in shutters so if can think of the sort
of standard brick pattern you can have
the outlines of brick shutters which it
does apply and and has been used in
conservation areas around the district
obviously that is part of this shop
front and there is concern about the
obtrusive nature of those shutters not
withstanding the fact that there is
obviously going to be a a functional
need for shutters for this type of
business and that is understood but the
style of them is is is is considered to
be obtrusive um it comes back to that
question that we've just been talking
about which is um we consider there is
harm to the conservation area by virtue
of the change that's been made to the
shop front um and we don't think that
the public benefits outweigh that harm
in this instance um with an objection
from the the conservation officer um so
in this instance we are recommending
refusal of the
application thank you chair thank you I
move that the officer's recommendation
is adopted with the vice chair please
second seconded thank you and um anyone
want to speak so councelor album
first yeah thank you chair um could I
just ask is the the the signage around
the top of the shatter boxes uh are
illuminated have they got consent as
well or have they not got consent
there's external illumination but um I'm
there's no planning permission but I
don't think they need planning
permission under the advert RS because
of the fact that this the the letters
are less than Sor this is so less than
75 cm in in length Okay
um I'm a bit torn with this to be quite
honest um
it is it does look better than the than
the
previous however
um I
think if we was to overturn the
recommendation for
approval then uh it's a possibility that
others along North down Road may wish to
copy I'm not saying they would or they
wouldn't but is it's a it's a
possibility so I'm just going to hold
far on my thoughts with that anyway
thank you chair
thank you councilor matterface thank you
chair just looking at the planning
history um there's appeal lodged uh
following refusal to replace the
windows replacement windows from Timber
to composite sash double glaze windows
and white are those the Wind have those
windows actually been put
in uh no that that um I need to check I
think believe this relates to the upper
floors yeah yeah yeah but
um it's difficult to tell whether
they're actually Timber or but so far as
you aware they are still the windows as
was I believe so yeah yeah I think it's
just a it's it's a propos I I can't I
can't say I can't say for certain but
it's a that's it's a separate cons
separate application a separate
consideration and um March the 1st of
this year installation replacement shop
front was refused so because that was
refused
presumably this is what we're looking at
now because he went ahead and put it in
is that correct uh no it was in situ
when that was
refused all
right if thank you if they were in situe
when that was refused obviously I wasn't
involved then um what has happened since
then and now he's put in the
retrospective the fact that the job had
been done is that it's it's it's the
same application has been submitted
again
yeah with there's there's an additional
there's additional information that's
been submitted to justify the proposal
and I think that's where the difference
comes now just for members reference
because this is something that does come
up occasionally um technically you can
submit a planning application for the
same thing
twice it's if they submitted it a third
time and it was refused it already been
refused to we can refuse to determine it
but we still obviously need to consider
the
application councilor Keane
thank you I mean I know North down Road
very well and anyone that's been along
there knows there's a huge variety of
different buildings now there are some
beautiful shop fronts there that we
definitely need to preserve but the
building that we're looking at was never
one of them and what they've done I
think is a huge Improvement to what was
there before and it's been a real
benefit to the area um in the terms of
increasing footfall especially at that
end of North down road now there are
some sort of U crime problems in that
particular area so sort of the shutters
were needed I appreciate there could
have been different types of shutters
but I think that's why you know for that
level of glass Frontage you absolutely
need that security for that building
otherwise you'd get broken windows all
stuck up like you know plenty of other
shops along North down Road have got
that become an eyesa so I I think this
is a great Improvement and I I would be
supporting approving what has
happened I have councelor ratan next
please um I completely agree with um
councelor Kean um you know having know
lived in Clifton WM My Life um and
actually have two properties along there
uh myself over the last 5 years years
I've have I've replaced four Windows
where they've been you know and we're
we're um there's nothing in there just
we're Nursery there's nothing for to
sell um there is a whole mix of shops
along there if you if you go um some
really nice ones some really ugly ones
um but I mean the officer um statement
that you know this was detriment to the
area I mean it's brought a really
rundown part of um of town into a real
vibrant area and even with the signage
it's very sort of old old school signage
they haven't gone for illuminated
signage um so I would definitely be uh
supporting this um
application councelor Alburn next yeah
thank you chair I I think what uh Mr
lion has has just said that this is uh
the second time this same application
has been submitted and it was refused
the first time so I cannot see how the
planning
committee can now overturn that and
approve it it we've already said it's to
be ref it's already been refused so why
would we why would we now why would this
committee now approve it thank
you I've you want to come back councelor
Kean yes please just to answer Council
Auburn's thing it was refused before by
the officers it's not been to planning
committee before thank you okay thank
you councelor mat no councelor
Wing uh we had a similar situation with
the accountants across the road and I to
declare an interest CU they're my
accounts and I did sign their petition
so I wasn't involved in that debate but
I think that was overturned as well I
also know uh North down Road very well
and I find it quite strange cuz we got
Costa Coffee further down the road which
is a similar sized building with with
stuff which doesn't fit the heritage in
fact it's probably worse than this uh I
I do think the shutters are really
clumsy and I wish during the daytime
they'd have them up because that would
improve the look during the day so I do
have a bit of a concern about the
shutters I'm sure there were other
designs that would have been less clumsy
that maybe could have been built into
the building uh the top part of the
building they're keeping the Heritage
there I mean even if they're not would
we can't see they're not wood so I
definitely think we've got to somehow
start moving forward with with some
non-wood materials that are sympathetic
to conservation zones quite a lot of
Europe already do quite a lot of this in
their historic areas and you wouldn't
notice unless you were an expert so I'm
of a mind to support the to
refuse refuse the officer's decision
this is where it gets confusing uh
because I do think it's tided up the
area and I do remember this area was
really
bad councilor matterface um sorry it was
refused by officers so it's come to the
committee has anything major changed in
the actual application anything that's
in the documentation from then to
now the fundamentals I mean it's the
same proposal so um there is there was
an additional statement that was
provided um which
identified uh the application that
counts the wing referenced which was
another case where it was was refused
and then they resubmitted and members
turned it around and approved it just to
come back on that point I think whilst
obiously the application is in front of
members and it's for you to determine um
it is it is an important point the fact
that it's it's it was refused by the
council and I just want to make that
quite clear that you obviously delegate
your authority to a lot of decisions to
to officers um but that doesn't
necessarily mean given that we've heard
some of the justification that's been
provided by um councilor Curry about the
background behind it it still needs to
be considered again on its own merits
tonight but just as a point normally of
order if it was identical and no
statement had come in I would be pushing
you to say you need to refuse this
automatically because there is no
differentiation between officers and
members in terms of where the decision
comes from it's the council thank
you councelor Garner yeah sorry to drag
this out but I just wanted to clarify
one thing or a couple of things in the
then the planning history in
2021 there is a retrospective
application for the proposed removal of
the existing shop front and
reinstatement of the traditional Timber
shop front which planning officers
granted with an expectation that the
applicant would reinstate with a Timber
shop front the applicant in fact didn't
reinstate with the timber shop front but
it implemented what we can see there and
has now come back has now come back with
retrospective again to get that approved
I'm I just getting that because I read
in the conservation officer's report
that that she was um a bit disappointed
about that
so sorry Char just come back on that the
so the the application came in that
application that said we're going to put
back the timber shop came in after the
enforcement inquiry because they had put
this shot front in um then it
subsequently led to the application
after that after that was approved um
obviously the application originally
then sorry then came into seek
retrospective consent for what's there
obviously there are a number of reasons
why anyone you know could put that
forward and that again just like the
foot path still needs to be considered
on its merits um thank
you okay if I have no more questions or
contributions we will now put the motion
for the officer's recommendation for
refusal to the vote those in favor of
refusal and those
against any
exensions okay thank you so that is
lost so I'll go back to Mr Livingston um
so we invite members to propose motion
to approve as you were obviously voted
down uh the the recommendation to uh
refuse um members have mentioned what
the reasons would be uh and so just to
capture some of those um in terms of the
benefits of The Proposal um I've heard
members mention about the increased
security um and also I members have sort
of mentioned in terms of the sort of
tidying up of that area I would say that
the probably the way to put that would
be the consistent design because
obviously it's more than just that
corner which has been changed it's the
rest of it so um in terms of if members
were to put forward a motion to approve
it's just a site that the the reasons
would be um that the increased security
and consistent design outweigh the harm
to the conservation era thank
you I've got Council Keem proposing and
councilor ran
seconding everyone in favor of that
please
four five
six and any against and any
extensions that's carried thank
you okay moving on to the next item on
the agenda
d10 the land between 47 and 49 rose
gardens min
uh public speaking first in favor I have
misle James you have three
minutes good evening and thank you for
letting me speak firstly apologies as I
know nothing about polies and I'm not
going to pretend to I brought the land
at rose gardens back in March this year
when I brought it it was an over
overgrown derel piece of land that over
many years has become a Dumping Ground a
nebor told me that prior to me
purchasing the land it was apparently
used as an allotment but they had lived
there for 15 years and it's been deric
throughout that time I brought it as I
want to provide adequate housing needs
for myself my daughter and my little
grandson my daughter went to Primary
School in St Nicholas and we loved the
school and Village ethos so we are
hoping that my grandson could attend
mster Primary in the future which I know
is an underdescribed fantastic School
rose gardens is a mixture of semi-
detached Bungalows some with loft loft
conversions and semi- detached houses I
believe that the majority are owned by
orbit housing my immediate neighbor is
doing a major extension that was
recently passed by thanet Council which
has already commenced he has written a
letter of support for my panning
proposal he also informed me prior to my
purchase there was a lot of antisocial
behavior on it and verine being present
due to the rubbish contaminants being
left on the land in the past I
understand the change could be
unsettling but I do feel that there has
been some untrue speculations within the
objections from the original plan
submitted the planners wanted some
amendments which myself and my architect
have worked closely with the planners
and agreed a solution and changed the
plans accordingly unfortunately when the
letters for the revised plans went out
to the local residents stating there had
been changes made a few residents
contacted me directly that were all in
favor for the initial planning phase as
they believe the planning has but they
believe the planning has now been
changed to build two houses thus why
they objected as I've got relationships
with the neighbors I asked them if they
had looked at the revised plans online
and they said no so so I advise them to
do so and explain that this is not the
case and Tau them through the plans
however they had already object objected
prior to this
conversation one of the objections said
she won't be able to access her car I
have been advised that she doesn't
actually even live in rose gardens and
resides in Brook brookman's close which
isn't connected and or accessed via rose
gardens before the resident the revised
plans went in I invited all the
residents to meet me at the land so I
could go through the drawings and
specifications with them as I know a lot
of them are elderly and have lived there
for many years so that if they had any
concerns at that time I could discuss
with them to see if they had any issues
of concerns I also told them this is
family homes but a couple of of the
objections are because they think it's
for profit I've been very diligent over
over making sure we are not overlooked
uh and insuring off street parking for
these properties Minster parish council
could agreed that this land was nice or
and welcome the development so so soon
as I brought it I had it cleared which
was a mammoth job bigger than I thought
and I needed 25 grab lers at a massive
cost whil clearing the and our Digger
was also vandalized having a brick th
thrown Through the Windows since the
early site Works commenced with the
clearance of rubbish de Etc I fenced the
land off to make it secure and stop
trespasses a final sentence for me is
that one of the comment comments I would
like to address is the suggestion of
increase of antisocial Behavior I do not
understand how having two family homes
on this site could cause an increase in
antisocial Behavior if this development
isn't approved then the land could end
up going back to being derelict and all
that comes with that
I have already provided the legal
agreement for the firm contributions I
thank you all for your
time thank you speaking under Council
rule 20.1 councelor Smith you have three
minutes marvelous thank thank you chair
um so this plan I've been approached by
um I've been approached by a very
concerned neighbor um and this plan
involves the imposition
on a tiny culdesac community of two much
uh imposition of two much larger
dwellings than surround it it is in
congruous and out of keeping with the
character and appearance of this small
culdesac uh neighbors feel strongly that
they will be overlooked and that the
development represents a drastic change
to the neighborhood that will impact
significantly on their sense of quiet
and
privacy and those are words which are
repeated across a number of
objections most of the surrounding
properties are single story Bungalows
many of which house elderly and
vulnerable residents who are reluctant
to object reluctant to object following
reports of a very aggressive response uh
to the first objection to appear on the
planning portal
parking arrangements are also deemed
inadequate and potentially dangerous
neighbors regularly use the small public
Alleyway which that runs alongside and
on which the proposed parking would
impinge this introduces an issue of
Public Safety uh potentially adding
physical injury to the insult of this
oversized
development based on the submitted plan
plans neighbors assert that first floor
windows on the East Elevation will
directly Overlook numbers one 41 43 45
and 47 and argu it arguably impact on
privacy for numbers 5 7 9 and 11 rose
gardens from the south elevation numbers
36 38 49 and 51 will be overlooked first
floor windows on the North elevation
will do likewise to numbers one and
three brockman's close and on the west
elevation the windows will open Overlook
numbers 19 21 23 25 27 29 and 31
Freeman's
rad neighbors appreciate that
restriction of permission for these
larger dwellings will limit uh the value
that the applicant can expect to realize
but this is appropriate given uh the
choice of site the plot is eminently
suitable for construction of one
dwelling of a single story which will
complement the existing neighborhood and
its vulnerable residents thank
you thank you the planning applications
manager will now outline the
report thank you chair um so the
application is for the erection of a
pair of semi- detached two-story uh two
bed dwellings uh main considerations are
impact on character appearance of the
area living conditions of neighbors
highway safety
um in terms of the principle of
development and the site lies within the
village confines so it is acceptable in
principle to develop this for housing
subject to all the normal other
considerations so this is a satellite
image of rose gardens coming off toil
street so the land that we are looking
at is at the end of the CER saac so you
can see the southern half uh of the the
CER sack end has um some garages and
hard surface and parking but the other
end has this this bit of land here which
um you can see obviously in this image
is um was sort of covered by scrub
growth and we'll look at some of the
photos just to give you some
context to the north you have another
area of hard standing with garages uh
and then you can see that there are
neighbors uh further north and then
you've got neighbors to the west and
then obviously the neighbors that are
directly adjacent on rose
gardens so this is the site in question
so again just to the north of that is
hard surfacing in the garages um it's
using existing vehicular access at the
end of rose gardens and existing drop
curb so this is the entrance to the site
so you can see the drop curb that's
there the neighboring property that's
been mentioned on the left of this image
uh that has consent for a rear extension
um you can see there which is um which
is number 49 um the pathway that's been
mentioned is the pathway that that's
just outside this uh fenced area here um
and on the right hand side you've got
number 47 so yeah looking at the semis
at the end of the um CER Sac um you've
got those two properties then looking
back the other way you can see behind
those two trees you've got another
Bungalow there which is number
47 so going into the site this is the
foot path itself that's been mentioned
so just to confirm one thing um straight
off off the bat there is a proposal for
a fence to be erected next to that foot
path um but there is no impingement on
that foot path the fence is outs is
within the site and not on that foot
path so that foot path will be
maintained this is a view looking back
uh along that foot path where the fence
would would run so you can see the
extent of the site and it's already been
mentioned that it has been
fenced so this is turning to the right
from that so you can see the extent of
the site you can see the hard surfacing
on the right hand side of the image
image that I mentioned to the north of
the site covering um some of the land
that's associated with some garages and
then looking back from that site which
is the neighboring site towards where
that entrance is you can see the area
that's been
fenced and then this is just showing
that hard surfaced area to the
North and then this is standing on the
foot path again looking across so you
can see those garages that I I mentioned
there and the site on the left hand
side
so this is an image this is actually
from 2009 it's taken from from Google
just to give a bit of an elevated
position to show you've got Bungalows at
the end of rose gardens but then on the
Northern side of rose gardens you have
two story properties that run uh
alongside an opposite the Bungalows and
then there's some twostory properties
that you can see at the end there when
you're closer to tots Hill
Street so as mentioned this is the py
stent um so what's proposed as already
mentioned is some semi- detached
properties there have been amendments
that we received as part of uh during
the course of the application uh
specifically the amendments were um I
suppose mainly trying to uh cover a
highways comment that come in that
you'll see in the report which raised
concerns um that the The Proposal hadn't
demonstrated that Vehicles can
successfully maneuver to turn around on
the site safely um which has been
provided and agreed by highways as
acceptable in terms of the traff in of
vehicles also a parking space has
actually been removed from The Proposal
that was off street so the previously
were four uh now there are three and
again that's to increase the
maneuverability so there is a space per
dwelling and I suppose an unallocated
visitor space as well that provision is
considered definitely to be acceptable
in accordance with Highway's guidance
for two bed dwellings um and on that
ground it's not considered that there is
harm to um you know substantial harm to
highway safety from lack of parking from
this proposal it's accommodated within
the site so you can see from this image
that there is Gardens provided for the
dwellings um and off street parking um
one of the issues that's been raised and
has dealt with in the report as was
concerns about the because of the width
of the access um what happens with the
fire Appliance so that's been looked at
specifically in terms of um the distance
for um the hose distance if a if a
vehicle came down to the end of rose
gardens um and just to make sure that
all elements of the the buildings can be
reached within 45 meters and that's not
a straight diagonal line going through
the building that's going sort around
the building effectively there is also
obviously as shown the access point to
the north with regards to those garages
as well uh and building RS will be
looking at that but that was one of the
concerns that was raised um by
residents um I just want to draw
attention to the point uh about fencing
so you won't be able to see The
annotation here which is talking about a
9 100 Mil fence to run alongside that
foot paath again you can see that foot
path that runs around here that is
outside of the extent of the site so
that will not be compromised by The
Proposal so in terms of the design um
the front elevation doesn't actually
have a u a door on it so it's the left
hand side image uh is what's facing that
parking area so it's render at ground
floor um and a normal normal roof above
um we'll look at specifically those two
vux windows because what's mentioned is
concerns that they would result in
overlooking to the neighbor at number 47
and onwards um the side elevation so
these the elevations that face um the
the the neighboring property to the
South um that has got the approval for
the extension so you see the the design
of the dwellings is that it would appear
from a bungalow at the front with a low
Eaves height to then include some first
floor accommodation and then the rear
there is a dormal window so the first
floor is clad um both the Dorma and the
return elevations are clad with cedar
cladding so in terms of the floor plans
for these dwellings um so you've got the
ground floor plan on the left hand side
so you can see the entrance doors are at
the side of the dwell uh side of the
Bungalows it's not considered that that
causes um I suppose it to look in
congruous in the street um it's um these
are relatively unassuming buildings even
though they've got first floor
accommodation uh and we'll look at the
relationship with the neighboring
property in terms of height in a second
um two bed dwellings um you've got a
roof light serving the front bedroom um
the officers referred to that in the
report to look at whether or that's
adequate Outlook um it is often the case
that that you have bedrooms in roof
spaces which obviously have Outlook
through vux windows it's not considered
to be again detrimental in terms of the
quality of accommodation that's being
created uh with the primary bedroom at
the rear with with a full normal height
window just to confirm that point um
this you can see on the left hand side
of this section the dormal window and
then at the front you can see the vux
windows that are the East windows that
face towards 47 um they this
demonstrates that the section on the
section that the sill height of that
window is 1.7 m above finished floor
level so in our view you cannot Overlook
The Gardens of those properties you are
simply looking up and
out in terms of the street scene then so
the top uh Street Scene is showing it in
relation to the the dwelling at number
49 so the one that has consent for a
rear extension you can see there's a
change in level across the site which is
the dotted line so there is going to be
some excavation to try and take the
height of that dwelling uh down um it's
not considered that the relationship
between the dwellings on either side uh
is obtrusive the rear sorry the the
bottom image there uh just shows the
relationship with number 47 um so the
Gap where the fence is here is where the
foot paath is that I've been mentioning
so again you can see how height-wise is
actually lower in Ridge than the
neighboring property and as well whilst
there are bungalows in the immediate
vicinity there are two story properties
in the road um and this wouldn't result
in a visual harm looking at the wider
character nor in the immediate vicinity
of the site in our
view so overall the development is not
considered to have caused harm to the
character appearance the area or living
conditions of neighbors um just to look
at this image in terms of the footprint
here uh to the South um this is a a
ground floor extension to this property
um which has been approved um that shows
the extent to which um there will be uh
you know development that's occurring in
in this area um because of the
relationship between where this dwelling
these these dwellings are cited is
further back from that front building
line so there's always a concern that
actually you're going not quite full
well you're not going going full two
story but you're going one and a half
stories and putting that in that
relationship with the neighbor could
have could cause harm but in this
instance there is an extent permission
it you know it is effectively the
fencing has already gone up and it's
it's it's Pro progressing so there is no
harm in our view caused to the
neighboring property from this proposal
it is also set away from the dwelling as
it is at the moment there is a gap to
the boundary as well and as mentioned
it's not a full two-story height it is
lower as shown from the elevations and
you can see the elevation here so
overall
um we we don't have concerns with
regards the carent appearance the area
or living conditions uh KCC highways are
I and I Satisfied by The Proposal um the
recommendation therefore is to defer and
Delegate for approval subject to The UU
for the spa contribution mention it's
been made of that that unilateral has
been submitted already um that will just
need to be checked to ensure that it
gives us the legal security but
obviously it would be it's still being
approved it would be approved on the
basis of that being acceptable but there
are safeguarding conditions and to very
quickly just touch on those um there's
one particular one that I did want to
mention as well as the standard
conditions with regards to drainage um
and Landscaping there is condition four
which is specifically for the
requirement for a construction
management plan and details of that to
be submitted because we are at the end
of a cold sack you do have a
relationship with neighboring properties
that we need to manage um yeah and and
therefore there are a number of um
provisors of what we would require to
see timing deliveries wheel washing
facilities routing of construction
vehicles parking and turning areas Etc
so we do think it's important to put
that condition on as well there's also
condition 11 where permitted development
rights are being taken away for Windows
to be inserted in the front elevation
which is the Eastern elevation at first
floor level because it wouldn't require
planning permission to put Windows in
there so that's why that permission
permitted development right has been
removed um but overall The Proposal is
recommended to defer and Delegate for
approval thank
you thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted would the vice
chair please
second seconded thank
you so do I have any speakers councilor
bford thank you chair yeah I we're only
looking at two stories here which has
been pointed out is not totally out of
keeping with the area I think there are
two um good additions to the housing
Supply the highways issues have been
addressed I'd like to support this
application councilor
iseki yeah I'd like to uh Support also I
think it looks uh looks like a need
little development only two properties
um yeah looks like a a a good good
development to me thank you Council Wing
uh I don't really have a problem with
the development at all I mean obviously
that building's going to encroach on the
new building so you know it's it swings
a roundabouts but I'm I'm glad there
will be a uh a construction management
plan because because we're building an
area where there are a significant
number of elderly elderly people then
obviously they get very concerned and
obviously sometimes there's an element
of inertia they don't like change so I
would I would say here publicly while
while the the the applicant is here that
due consideration going forward needs to
be considered of those neighbors
particularly in light of the the
possibility that some of them may
believe that they've been dealt with
aggressively because of objecting so you
know it's always tight it's a tight
sight there's going to be noise there's
going to be vibrations but certainly
trying to get that a proper construction
management plan that is in the context
of the environment not not just in terms
of the type the type location but also
there's a lot of elderly people there as
well thank you anyone
else in that case uh we will now put the
motion for the officer's recommendation
for deferral and delegate to the vote
those in
favor was
that y That's carried thank
you right
next agenda item is uh land to the north
of Fair laon Road and the west of
Northwood Road
broadstairs firstly public speaking in
favor of the application is Miss Nicola
Kohl's you have three
minutes thank you chair good evening I'm
speaking on behalf of the applicants
Knights Lodge construction the
development proposed this through this
full planning application relates to an
allocated housing site and will enable
the delivery of 38 sustainably located
dwellings through constructive
discussions with Council officers the
proposal has undergone an iterative
design process resulting in a reduced
number of dwellings from 44 to 38 at
this reduced density the development
exhibits a softer less engineered layout
it is agreed with officers that this
strikes an appropriate balance between
meeting the national objective of making
efficient use of land whilst making
opportunities for um landscaping and
biodiversity enhancement and creating a
high quality environment for residents
the notional capacity for this
allocation is identified within the
council's development plan as 45
dwellings the allocation also includes
land to the south of the application
site that it's recently secured
permission for housing collectively the
proposed developments would equate to 41
dwellings across the total allocation
therefore falling below the council's
estimated capacity on-site trees
protected by a recent preservation order
are to be retained and safeguarded the
proposed landscape master plan includes
a generous native tree planting strategy
of over 60 individual specimens this
will further enhance the character and
appearance of the site and its
Effectiveness can be heightened through
the appropriate management regime the
council's arbac cultural officer is
supportive of the proposed strategy we
are also pleased to report that working
with the council's housing officers the
application includes a policy compliant
Quantum of on-site affordable housing
which comprises a mix of first homes and
social rented all other developer
contributions as reported on page7 of
the agenda genda are to be met through
the completion of a legal agreement this
will ensure that the development meets
the relevant social infrastructure
requirements responses from statutary
consules have revealed no technical
constraints to development officers are
satisfied that the layout is compatible
with neighboring buildings and spaces a
construction management plan will ensure
that the construction phrase is
appropriately managed in the interest of
residential amenity this is a fully
policy compliant Housing Development
that will realize the sustainable
objectives of both National and local
planning policy members are therefore
respectfully invited to support their
officers recommendation as set out thank
you
chair thank you speaking against the
application is Mr Steve Smith three
minutes I've been given three minutes to
slot to emphasize my objections but with
a major project like this one is
proposed I find it very
difficult but what I can do is I can
just State a few statements I've just
listened to what come across there and
it all sounds very credible but take
yourself back to when this application
first was put in it was quite easy to
say yes we'll build 45 properties what
you didn't nobody told you was there was
cedar trees there 100 years old
consequently they were all cut down why
to make room for 14 or 15 detached
houses everybody in Northwood Road in
broadstairs was up in arms
we contacted the planning and anybody
else that would possibly
listen all of a sudden a TPO is issued
bit late CU all the trees are now cut
down the only ones that stayed were the
ones that the they thought they could
just get a road around there which
brings me to my next point a road an
access road by their
own documents it clearly shows that a
dust cart could not get in there without
crossing over to the other side of the
road in Northwood
Road once that vehicle is in this
will'll call it an
estate there is no way in a Month of
Sundays could any other vehicle of which
there's going to be possibly over a
hundred get in or out of that
estate one of the properties I've I
think they call it
H3 this has been put on the Eastern side
of the pro of the
premises and it overlooks my house the
back wall would be approximately 13
ft from my little verander at the back
of my
house with first floor Windows
overlooking my property I bought this
house 30 years ago and I didn't expect
to have a house or in some of the
drawings they've got they've got two
properties there trying to tell me it's
two small bungalows well a bungalow in
my age was a single story building not
going up to the first floor with Windows
overlooking my
property the whole thing is a disaster
the access and the erress to the
property on their drawings is it
indicating somewhat 10 m
wide true facts it's 4.8 M wide that
doesn't include any Paving or anything
like that for
pedestrians plus there's a dirty grade
Telegraph Pole right slap bag in the
middle of
it how the council has allowed this to
get to this stage I do not
know the entirety of Northwood Road has
complained about it the wildlife the
trees everything has been totally
decimated you had a bat report they
turned up there they turned up to check
for bats in the cedar
trees they've reported within that
report oh well unfortunately the cedar
trees have all been cut
down the whole thing has been a disaster
from start to
finish I sent letters to Mrs fibbin I've
had no response whatsoever there's been
no correspondence to the public at all
the whole thing is
disgusting I could go on for another
hour but I'll stop at that I I do need
you to wind up please thank you um next
speaking against the application is Mrs
Margaret Bennett Goodman you you also
have 3 minutes please right thank you
very much for the opportunity I would
say I've already submitted three
responses can you put your microphone on
thank you um I've already uh submitted
three responses so this is number four
and it's in a way a summary because the
others are very
detailed I'm objecting to the proposed
development for two main reasons the
development itself and the effect it
will have on the environment and
surrounding area the single access often
partly obscured by Park cars is a major
concern for all residents in the area
the potential for horrendous accidents
is considerable in spite of the opinions
raised by conine in their report this
single access also has a significant
impact on the development itself and on
those people who might live there these
38 dwellings will accommodate between
107 and 186 people it is generally
accepted that when a large number of
people live in close proximity it often
gives rise to social tension here it is
further exacerbated by the fact that is
completely enclosed and hidden from view
whether the parking allocation will be
sufficient to prevent neighbor disputes
of this kind is
doubtful the development provides for
the statutory allocation of affordable
housing this too could cause tension the
size and appearance of these dwellings
provides a very obvious distinction
between the Haves and the Have Nots an
enclosed development can also create the
possibility for criminal activities
there's already been a significant drugs
bust at 129 Northwood Road earli this
year if this should be the case it would
be extremely difficult to report it as
the complainant could be easily
identified any police veilance would be
very obvious vehicles from the
development on Northwood Road will
additionally impact the Margate Road and
Westwood Road causing the current
gridlocks to extend even further once
the 80 dwellings at thanet reach are
built with another possible um 120 cars
the gridlock will be permanent
previously I said that the development
is hidden from View and unw activities
could take place in secret the developer
himself proved this last year by failing
a number of trees contrary to the
conditions imposed in the relevant
documentation fortunately complaints
made to the planning team stopped the
fing this also shows he does not care
much about the environment the landscape
design shows a substantial amount of new
planting that outside the cages is to be
maintained by a management company TDC
Council Tree strategy states that trees
must be maintained until maturity which
according to the r is two to three
seasons remaining trees must be
maintained by the owners how will TDC
enforce this if necessary unfortunately
30% of newly planted trees die within
the first year there's every possibility
that this will occur here reducing the
calming and softening effect on this
Urban rather utilitarian development and
the potential for the removal of harmful
exhaust particles from traffic in the
whole
area the ccg believes that £ 38,1 196
will mitigate the impact of this
development on the delivery of general
Practice in this area which is debatable
I've already commented a great deal on
this issue in both my previous responses
but I want to make crystal clear that as
the NHS knows thanet is the worst area
in the country for attracting doctors to
jges and practices and it is doctors
that are desperately needed Rick ett
wants to attract new people to thanet
which is very laudable but earlier this
year he said the infrastructure was
overwhelmed so perhaps he could explain
how developments of this size plus those
at thanet reach and tyon Rose could
improve the situation please think past
the new housing bonus I'm not against
any development of the site although the
single access will always be a major
concern unless devel just just one a few
more sentences I would love to see a
development where the developers thought
through about people who will actually
live there and the architects who
naturally want to push the boundaries of
design consider that most people do not
want their boundaries pushed
unfortunately this is still very much
overdeveloped and as such it will have a
negative impact on the area PS does the
developer know about solar panels thank
you um I now pass to the principal
planning officer Emma to outline the
report
please thank you chair the application
site is is outlanding red here so to the
bottom of this slide is fairon road on
the right hand side is Northwood Road um
at this point here is the existing
access into the site
the site's um an undeveloped piece of
land historically it's um been used as
an orchard um there's two existing
buildings on the site um and the site is
um Edge of Town Center with the um edge
of of Westwood Town Center being to the
left of this slide so this is an AAL
view of um the the site so again you can
see the access coming into the site from
Northwood Road um in this location here
the boundary of the site um runs along
here where you can see an existing HED
line um and runs along this location
here and to the left of the screen you
can see um the existing retail units in
the town center and again you can see
Fair long road to the bottom of this
slide um you can see existing pattern of
development of properties in Northwood
Road which um Range um in in size and
and design so you can see there's pairs
of semi- detached properties um and
there's also a range of um also Terrace
units you can see in this location here
as well this again is a view then
looking towards Northwood Road so just
showing the rears of the existing
properties that were back onto the
eastern boundary of the site um so you
can see in this location here they are
um Bungalows but many of those have um
Extended at roof level to create first
FL accommodation and on the left hand
side you can see there's existing two
story properties that back onto the the
site on the right hand side you can see
that there's an existing Bungalow um
which would be just south of the access
so the application site extends into
this location here so this existing
building and this existing building
would be um demolished um as part of The
Proposal so this is just um a plan
showing the um local plan and the
housing allocation for the site so the
um hashed Brown area is the housing
allocation the application site boundary
runs along here so you can see the
darker brown line is the application
site that runs along in this location
here and to the bottom of this area is
um the adjacent site so um the boundary
of this site um extends along line here
and to the south of this members will
remember you've seen a few times um the
application to the um end of fairon road
which has has come before you um and
there's been approval for um six houses
and then more recently for three houses
in this location here um this area to
the north is also allocated housing site
this hasn't yet um come in as an
application to us on the left again you
see the the blue is the Town Center um
and then you can see that this
Millennium Way running along the top of
the site here so again just just another
a view just you see the whole sign
context so this everything south of
Millennium Way is allocated housing um
it's split into two um um housing um
allocation so the housing allocation for
this site is for notional 45 dwellings
um and as mentioned um approval has
already been granted for six and then
subsequently for three units in this
location here um that would come within
that 45 um unit allocation and then
there's a further allocation for
additional units um here but that falls
obviously outside this this application
so these are just from photos showing
you the site this is the existing access
into the site from Northwood Road um so
you can see in the in the um distance
there the two existing buildings to be
demolished and then this is just another
view so you can see Northwood Road and
this is the axis on the right hand side
here and you can just see there's a
range of property Styles and types in in
the road so there's a mix of semi-
detached detached Terrace units two
stories single Stories the real mix of
of different style properties but this
site itself is set back from the road it
wouldn't necessarily be seen in the
context of of the existing properties
it's quite a secluded site this is
inside the site looking back towards
Northwood Road so Northwood Road is in
this location here again you can see and
the existing buildings to be removed and
you can now start seeing some of the um
trees running along the boundary of the
site um and again just another view
there so again Northwood Road um over in
this location here Fair Lawn is to the
right hand side and then again this is
again the neighboring properties Behind
These existing trees so these trees are
proposed to be retained as part of the
application and then this is now looking
again towards the eastern boundary but
now moving towards the northern boundary
of the site so you can see um um just
beyond here um an application was
approved for a care home so that's
currently under construction just beyond
this Northern
boundary um and again just showing the
existing um hedge row so along the
northern boundary they're looking to
retain existing hedge
row and then just again another view
looking um towards um faom Road and
again there so fair Road being in that
location there and again there so um
this just to start with um the uh issues
regarding the trees so the application
did come in a few years ago and um
following its submission there was um
some felling of trees on the site so at
the mo at the time of fell in no trees
were protected so there was nothing um
unlawful um that took place on the site
obviously we would have been Keen to
have assessed the trees through this
application and and and looked at looked
at that through the proposal but it's
inevitable that some trees would have
needed to have been removed given the
fact this is an allocated housing site
in order to fit the number of units on
which are um are allocated within the
policy in order to secure our our
housing um requirement for the district
we we need to make sure we're securing
the numbers that we're trying to
radicate these sites for so to do that
we would have expected to see some loss
of trees on the site so the the trees
have been removed her in this location
here so there was a a run of trees
running through the center of the site
um there was a tree in this location
here which um as you can see would have
needed to been removed in order to
achieve access into the site and then
these areas to the left um aren't aren't
really mature trees they were more sort
of hedge row style smaller trees so
there was nothing really of any
substance in this location here so the
trees that we um have since looked at
and I've been on site with the um
articulture officer to assess the trees
are along this B foundary um this tree
here is the one that you saw in the
photos which is quite a large mature um
Sycamore that we're very keen to see
retained and there was two other trees
along this boundary and then the tree
along the northern boundary that we were
also very keen to see retained and so um
following that site visit we did place a
TPO on those trees um for retention and
they are shown to be retained through
this application so this is just showing
the TPO map for the TPO tree so those
those four trees are to be retained so
the application was initially submitted
for 44 units this is the block plan of
the application that was submitted um
The Proposal um included a flat block on
the um bottom left hand corner of the
site and the rest of the development you
can see was a mix of um semi- detached
units um and they were all quite close
to each other and within the center of
the site they were all quite close to
the frontage there wasn't much space
around the units concern was raised with
the density of of this development and
it was um recommended that the number
was reduced especially in order to look
at um replacement trees to overcome the
loss of trees that had taken place on
the site so um The Proposal is now for
38 units so it's dropped in six units
and this is now the proposed um
layout so the layout is looking at a
flat block to the center of the site and
then around the edge of the site is a
mix of houses they range in height two
to three story all of the rear um ease
level are two stories so some of the
front just have some Gable FES with um
second floor windows but you can see in
terms of the um layout they're all
setback there's um uh Garden um spaces
to the front the flat Block in the
middle has quite a lot of um landscaping
around it with quite a spacious setting
um you can see areas of of um again soft
Landscaping in front of it just creating
imunity space so as you enter the site
you would be um facing towards the flat
block which will be a feature building
to the center of the site um in terms of
parking all of the units are provided
with two parking spaces um other than
the um the flats which have one parking
space and there's eight visitor parking
spaces also proposed um in terms of the
actual access so it's it's using the
existing access into the site and then a
loop road is being created that runs
around but it doesn't fully um extend
round so Vehicles would have to turn to
come back out again so there's
pedestrian and cycle access the whole
way around but um Vehicles would be
forced to turn and this is in order to
um slow down Vehicles it's a shared
surface it's being created around the
site with the aim of of reducing um
vehicle
speeds so in terms of the unit styles
that is quite a modern design although
um everything is pitch roof to try and
and be in keeping with the surrounding
area so I just going to show you a few
of the unit styles that are proposed um
so this is one of them with a a Gable
front as you can see this one does have
um second floor windows at the front but
at the rear it's
twostory um you can see that most of
them have floor to se sealing glazing um
there's a mix of materials used on them
including white render um Timber
cladding and a mix of bricks and
aluminium Windows this is a small
Bungalow which um is towards the front
of the
site and then again another um VAR
variation for different unit styles
again just a Gable frenches there with a
glazing and this is again is another
tight so this is more the Terrace units
of this style that run along the western
boundary of the
site and again another one but slightly
wider um so those those were the Terrace
units run along the left and then along
the north we've got the detached units
The Bungalow that you just saw is in the
bottom right hand corner um that's there
because the building that fronts onto
Northwood Road is also a bungalow so we
need to have quite a small scale build
in order to avoid any Overlook to the
neighbors so now I just to show you the
elevations for the flat block which is
in the center of the site so this is the
development of of the flat block so it's
two to three stories in high whilst it's
quite large building it is very much
broken down into these three different
elements um you can see the the frontage
shows um the floor to seeding glazing
with some setback um balcony areas um
and these side elevations you can see
the interesting roof form um because
they're in the center of the site it's
going to be visible from everywhere you
look so it's very important to make sure
that every elevation is um has interest
and you can see that each elevation does
that there's lots of openings on each
side there's a mix of materials um and
just the the um say the me the roof form
creates quite an interesting building
shape that is considered to be quite an
interesting feature building towards the
center this is just another um set of
images they're provided of the
perspective um views of that
building um and these are just the floor
plans showing them so these units have
um the flats in it so two um two bed
Flats on each uh
floor and then you can see the that's
the three story element there so these
are some Street elevations showing how
the buildings would look so this is the
um Southern boundaries you can see the
the um the Bungalow just as you enter
the site and then you can see um the
two-story um buildings that run along
there so again interesting range where
you've got the gables and then the hitch
roof um properties then this is the
Terrace block which runs along the
western boundary of the site and then
the top one here again shows the detach
units that run along the northern um
boundary of the site and then the bottom
one here is the properties that back on
to the existing proper properties in
Northwood Road um so again these were
amended because originally they did have
some um upper level windows in the rear
so again in order to avoid neighbors
these have been um amended but they are
three story at the front looking into
the
site um in terms of materials and hard
surfacing um this is the um hard
surfacing plan just showing that all of
the hard surfacing would be um permeable
Paving so there's no tarmac within the
site so it's just four different styles
of Paving that would run around creating
quite a nice um environment and then
this is the Landscaping plan so this is
a landscaping master plan so it's not
the full plan the full plan would be um
submitted via condition but what this
shows is as um the intentions for new
planting within the site and existing
retention of planting um so you can see
the existing TPO trees running along the
eastern boundary of the site and again
along the north here the existing um TPO
tree um you can see there's lots of new
um tree planting within the site so
again to the front of the flat blocks to
the rear these are all amenity spaces so
they everything outside the um dotted
yellow line would be um communal imunity
space which would be um looked after
under the Landscape Management plan and
so where there sometimes are concerns
that that planting Falls within CS of
properties and therefore wouldn't be
protected into the future this would be
protected because it doesn't fall within
those cures and we could protect it with
the Landscape Management plan so all of
these um immunity spaces to the front
here and as you enter the side either
side are all um in that space um and as
you as well just general um franches of
property as well as parking is provided
they've all managed to achieve um small
front Gardens as well um along the
western boundary there's some existing
hedge Ro but the um arbic culture
officer suggested that maybe a
replacement of that with some more
native species would be an improvements
so that's been
proposed um in terms of ecology
obviously there has been some loss of um
habitat through some clearance of the
trees and things on the site um under
the um uh ecology side of things um an
assessment was submitted which looked at
all the protected species within the
site there was nothing identified as
being present within the site at all um
K KCC have looked at it and just have
recommended an ecological impact
assessment is submitted um via condition
but as part of this Landscaping um
master plan they are proposing to
provide um Tim Timber log piles bug
hotels bat boxes and bird boxes within
the site which will help to um help with
ecological enhancements within the site
so ktc biodiversity have have no
concerns with it in terms of the impact
on neighbors so this plan here you can
see the outline of the most recently
approved um neighboring development
which was was for three houses so these
were two Bungalows on the right hand
side and this was a two-story dwelling
here so these properties would back on
to um these properties so when
considering both applications have been
looking at the potential impact from
Neighbors to to one another from this
application we've been looking at window
placements to make sure that there's um
minimum overlooking to these properties
and again on the right hand side you'll
end up with a bungalow next to these two
Bungalows here which again in terms
of in terms of relationship there would
be no no interruptions please in terms
of relationship there' be no first floor
Windows overlooking between these these
um these units so in terms of distance
currently from the proposed rear
elevation of these proposed dwellings to
the nearest existing property in Fon
Road obviously not these because they're
not currently constructed um there's a
distance of um 34 M so there's no
existing neighbors that would be
affected um and um as I said
consideration has been given to um this
this um scheme that has already been
approved which is a material
consideration in terms of the impacts on
properties in Northwood
Road um as you can see in terms of the
relationship the greatest distance is um
to the units to the the north of this
slide so you can see this is the
greatest distance this is a distance of
42 M from um the rear of this property
to the rear of this property Northwood
Road the closest relationship is um from
this unit here to um number 76 and
78 um there's a distance of 25 M to the
um rear Conservatory of number 78 which
is the closest property and then 30 m to
the main dwelling so um given this
distance this exceeds the the distance
that we usually consider to be
acceptable for overlooking on top of
that we also have the retention of the
trees through the TPO which will help
with screening um and also we've removed
um permitted development rights to allow
for any um alterations at roof level
that could provide for any additional
second floor windows that would face
towards those neighbors so given all
those things it's considered the impact
on privacy of these neighbors is is
acceptable in terms of the um vehicular
impact the these plans are submitted
just showing um turning into the site so
2.4 4X 43 M visibility space can be
achieved to the access achieving a safe
access into the site um a footpath would
extend into the site as well creating um
safe um movement for pedestrians and
then these plans show turning of um
waste Vehicles into the site which
highways have have um raised no concerns
with so these are 30 m um Vehicles
showing that they can go into the site
and move around the loop turn and um
come back out again so highways have
raised um no concerns of the access or
with the um layout and in terms of
vehicle movements they've said that
there won't be imp severe impact on the
highway um with the proposed development
looking to provide on average only one
additional vehicle movement per 3
minutes um in terms of affordable
housing 30% is proposed which includes
70% affordable rent and 30% first homes
with a good mix of unit um types um
proposed all Financial contributions are
being secured through um a legal
agreement which we will um wait to um be
submitted but all of heads of terms for
that have been agreed um and just in
terms of drainage um The Proposal is to
connect onto the existing compin
combined sewer in Northwood Road um
Southern water have said that there is
capacity for both um surface water and
foul um drainage onto that um combined
sewer although there is some preference
from ktc for infiltration and that can
come later though through a condition
submission so um it is recommended it be
deferred and delegated for approval it's
um
um subject to the legal agreement coming
in and the safeguarding conditions but
it is is recommended for for this on the
basis that it's a sustainable site Eder
Center allocated housing site and
therefore the social and and econ
economic benefits of this scheme are
considered to weigh the envir outweigh
the environmental harm and as you can
see from the Landscaping there's lots of
U mitigation that is proposed to try and
deal with the concerns that residents
have raised regarding the loss of the
trees and the habitat so um the
recommendation is to defer and delegate
thank you
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted with the vice
chair please second seconded thank you I
have councelor gner
first thank you yeah I I uh called this
plan and application in about two years
ago think when it was initially raised
um because I had a number of um
significant
concerns uh at that time about the loss
of trees potential loss of trees the
potential impact on uh
biodiversity um and over the last couple
of years see that impact has been a lot
of that impact has already been realized
so we've lost a lot of the lot of the
trees and as we've heard uh lot of the B
the wildlife that did live there is
already um gone and now the concerns
significant concerns I think the local
residents have have out
outlined um stem from what I consider to
be an
overcrowded
overdeveloped um plan
firstly I mean I accept and acknowledge
this is a this is land allocated for
housing as as is stated in the local
plan um but that isn't the end of it um
we've already seen that the over the
iterations of this plan application the
number of houses on on here has been
reduced from 45 to now 38 and I think
there's still a way to go before this is
an
acceptable um an acceptable
development
um I just want to highlight a couple of
areas where this overcrowding and
overdevelopment has impacted and the
first of these is with with the Highway
solution as you can see this I'm glad
we've got this picture up and those of
us who live locally or I most of us were
familiar with Northwood Road those of us
who might represent the neighboring Ward
will know this road has become busier
and busier with more parking along that
road over the years um and this
development is not going to is going to
make that even worse and I don't think
there has been enough consideration
about this and in fact I've looked
through the various KCC highways reports
on this and they've raised a number of
significant concerns over each
iteration um going including uh visitor
parking Bays not being enough the uh
design inappropriate for a Suburban
location uh and they in fact have said
that vehicle movements are going to be
higher than that which would normally be
permitted by the Kent design guidelines
and I think this is still the case and
in fact we've now been left with a bit
of a
haphazard weai in for an accident to
happen type design we got a single
entrance I went and had a look at it
today that entrance to that site which
will be the only access point for
anybody in a car on a bike a pedestrian
emergency vehicle a refug vehicle any
vehicle will any vehicle any person will
have to access through that single site
onto northward Road the larger Vehicles
will need to swing out to the other side
of the road to get in it's a shared
surface um so you know there's mini
minimal or limited Del delimination
between where you walk where you cycle
where you drive I mean I I couldn't
quite make make head or tail of it in
terms of where the markings are for who
can which vehicle and which pedestrian
which cyclist can go where and it it
doesn't even go all the way around I
think it's it's a it's a bit of a
disaster waiting to happen
myself uh the other impact that this
overcrowding and overdeveloped site
potentially will have is on biodiversity
and again I read through all of the
report ports attached to the plan
application and in fact KCC
biodiversity have over the years raised
a number of concerns about this and at
one point they they highlighted the fact
that actually there isn't going to be
potentially isn't going to be any net
gain in biodiversity here I mean it that
picture does look very green there is
some nice green bits on there but in
fact that this is going to be a by
biodiversity loss as far as I can see
and as far as I'm concerned there's a
loss loss of all current habitats on
site as has happened and I think there
are actually minimal green spaces being
developed there um and as you could you
can just see by comparing the G The
Gardens and the land around the houses
on Northwood Road with the H the houses
and blocks on the on the site they're
they're smaller you know the the gardens
are smaller I it's nice to see there is
a bit of a front garden but it's smaller
and the the one other area I wanted to
to mention which was mentioned which was
the the um clinical commissioning group
submission which which they said there's
going to be 107 new patient
registrations and therefore mocks word
summerill New inton Road dashwood
Medical and the gra surgeries which are
I think acknowledged to already be
overcrowded and I realize there's not a
lot we can necessarily do about that but
there it's another this is another one I
compared it with the the British gas
site application that we approved last
year which is going to see 156 new
patients going to mocks word St Peters
are North down this isn't something
necessarily that we can deal with here
in in this meeting but it's something
that we all need to be aware of that you
know our doctors have become our GP has
become more and more and more
overcrowded so I mean I I do have
significant concerns about this and I
share them with the Bard sors Peters
Town Council who had significant
concerns about the overdevelopment of
this site and recommended refusal rcap
Town Council had
similar concerns about o development and
they recommend refusal as did the Brad
stairs um Brad stairs Society so I mean
I'm obviously interested to hear how
other people think might the significant
overdevelopment concerns are being
tackled here but I'm I'm going to
struggle to approve this um it's it's a
housing site it needs houses on it but
this is the wrong design I think and I I
probably will vote against this and ask
for them to come back with a much more a
much a m a much better design um for us
to consider and potenti approve thank
you um just to come um back on a few of
those points I just want to sort of
emphasize you mentioned quite a few
times about the number of units and
overcrowding um but just to remind
members this is an edge of Center site
um we I mean whilst it is in quite a
Suburban location it's lies adjacent to
the town center and in terms of distance
um to reach the Town Center is Edge of
Town Center although high is class at
Suburban um but in terms of like density
it's 29 JS per Hector so it is actually
very low density in town centers we
would expect a lot higher edge of
sensors also quite high so at 29 per
heor this is actually quite low density
um and also it falls below the number
we've um sort of allocated for within
the local plan so in terms of
overcrowding in our view it it achieves
what we're looking for in terms of the
allocation and is suitable in this
location given the size the plots I mean
you've mentioned size of gardens they
are 10 to 15 Metter in depth which is
pretty standard for a garden and we've
got a real range of mix of units here
with quite a few detach units so there's
a there is it is in keeping with the
pattern of surrounding development in
our in our view um just something I I
fail to mentioned I've just realized
where you mentioned about um the only
access point being onto Northwood Road
is that um they are actually also
proposing a pedestrian link um in the
north um point of this of this slide so
this would be looking to go through the
um adjacent housing allocation site up
to Millennium way to provide um direct
um pedestrian and cycle links to the
town center so that would be um in this
location here cutting through obviously
is dependent upon the neighboring schem
coming in and also looking at that um
connection but that's our intention is
to try and improve connections with the
Town Center um and then in terms of the
other points you've made you've
mentioned you said about net
biodiversity net gain there's not
actually been an assessment in terms of
whether there's biodiversity net gain on
this site or not but but as you can see
there is is there is a lot of greenery I
mean yes we've lost some trees but they
are proposing a lot of replacement trees
with up to 60 um provided through the um
condition requiring the planting plan to
come in along with other ecological
enhancements and whilst this application
has been in for a long time therefore
there's lots of referenes to references
to concerns from um KCC biodiversity and
KC highways in the comments at this
moment in time they now have no
objections with the plans that are
before you they have no no objections to
and and consider the access to be safe
and the Turning areas to be safe and the
number of parking spaces to be adequate
so um I feel that that that does sort of
hopefully address your your concerns
with
that yeah thank you one thing I did want
to add about highways um yeah the final
comments in the report did seem bit
incomplete because it said we're happy
with this as long as the conditions are
implemented but it didn't then say what
the conditions were so I did have a look
in there
dated the 23rd of October from a few
weeks ago and I think there were nine
nine conditions listed in there which I
couldn't see them all in the conditions
on the on the um in the report at the
top of the report there there seemed to
be a a few
missing I did query that one and I was
reassured that it is in the conditions
can we can we note which one it
is um we we what if if we let the debate
go forward what we'll do is we'll we'll
just come back on that because I believe
that there are informatives on there
which aren't specifically necessary
conditions but there are standard
informatives that we put on any
permission when it involves any
interaction with the highway so we can
clarify that point Council matterface
thank you my question is much shorter
than my comment um I know it's an
allocated site Mrs fibbin mentioned the
number allocate number allocated is more
than what's actually gosh I'm losing my
voice
um more than this report how many was it
actually allocated for in the approved
local
plan s um it it's the notional
allocation so we basically carried out
an assessment probably I'm assume
usually it's based on 30 dwellings per
hectare so the notional number for
allocation is 45 but that includes this
site and the site below so if you are
taking the the three units that have
most recently been approved on the site
below that would mean that we'd be
looking for up to 41 units ideally on
this site and the obviously proposing
38 councilor Mo yes thank you chair uh I
think Council Garner's quite abely
raised the concerns that I had um but
just nitpicking we keep saying the town
center it's not the Town Center nowhere
near the Town Center you're talking
Westwood cross I think and we need to
make sure we're talking about the right
thing um because I don't think the Town
Center's moved since I've lived here
yeah just to confirm we we mean the town
center of Westwood cross it's it's a
designated as a town center in the local
plan and has been since the previous
local plan so when we say the town Cent
we're not talking about broadstairs
we're talking about West Cross just to
be clear on
that sorry this this this is just
showing that so the blue is the Town
Center that's allocated Town Center in
in the local
plan councilor
Wing uh thank you chair is there a is is
there a elevation is there an elevation
of the the block the three story Block
in the in the middle in context of the
rest of it around it because I I think I
I I possibly missed that or there wasn't
one no there isn't it's not part of the
street elevation so the street
elevations went around each of the
houses and then this is in the center so
that's that's quite cuz I would have
like to have seen the impact of that
extra story on the on the on the on The
View obviously you've got Circle round
and if I'm this side of the circle
looking across it across that lot I
would have liked to have seen how how
these buildings here view in in terms of
AC you know cross-section through the
site so it you know I'm a bit I'm a
bit uh disappointed that that view isn't
there for me to look at and also the
allocation of social housing what
percentage is
it um so there's so we've got 30%
affordable housing being proposed um and
of that there would be 70% um affordable
rent and then 30% first homes could you
identify them on the on the site plan
please
sorry Emma it's very late for me to be
asking you this
question it must be useful in future if
we already have this marked on that
diagram to save a bit of
time it's it's the ones on the left hand
on the western side so this I was going
to make a guess that it was those ones
based on those units being the smaller
units and I find that I mean I don't
know what your word to use I wanted to
use the word offensive that a
development a development you know I I
think one of the residents who objected
mentioned them the Haves and the Have
Nots and you know it would be really
lovely to see a developer give
affordable housing at the same size
standard and quality as the rest of the
houses on the on on on whatever the
development is it would also be really
great if particularly the social housing
had so panel so that we can try and
reduce the cost fuel bills of of people
who who who maybe aren't as fortunate as
as many of us to own their own housing
so I I find that really disappointing um
we constantly look at developments where
the social housing is stuffed in a
corner away from the rest and it's just
socially divisive so I I I'm I can't I
need to see the elevation of the bit
across the middle I also need I'd also
like to see those social houses
actually represent the size and quality
of the quality is probably there but
certainly look the same as as a similar
or even be
dispersed amongst the uh the development
so that we don't have this
Division and just to come back on that
point so in terms of the size of the
units the affordable units has four one
bed 4 two bed and three three bed units
so there is a range of size of units
obviously they all meet the space
standards because they all have to meet
the space standards um that set out with
policy and National guidance of two of
those units as well are wheelchair um
adaptable units so that is also being
provided so yes they're terrorist and
there's not a mix in terms of the the
type of housing but in terms of sizes
they would all be meeting minimum space
standards and they've got adequate depth
Gardens they've all got the same amount
of
parking I sort of understand that but
just looking at that site they've
obviously there's less space for those
buildings than there are the rest of the
buildings I'd also really love to see an
overlay if we could overlay the waste
vehicle access on top of this one and we
all know because we all live in a high
density area that we have cars parked
all over the place and I don't think the
waste vehicle will get round if there's
a few car parked cars out on the street
and that is definitely going to happen
so I also have real
concerns about uh our waste teams or
anybody else being able to access uh
that safely I I don't know how they
manage most of the time in in a lot of
our areas but but you know we need to
make it as easy as possible for them so
you know a couple of parked cars and
that vehicle isn't going to get
round do I have any other question
councelor
bayford thank you chair
I originally um felt this did seem like
overcrowding but having listened to the
listened and seen the
report I feel it's probably sustainable
counc Baer could you pull your
microphone toward you a little bit sorry
y y
sorry right um I have to say I think we
would struggle to defend an appeal if if
we go against this um and I also think
we need to be a little bit careful what
we wish for because it is designated for
housing um I'm not sure that we're going
to get anything that is more pleasing
thank
you any other questions or
comments in that
case say it carry on my pages um we put
the motion for the officer's
recommendation for deferral to the vote
those in
favor and those
against any
abstentions that's carried thank
you
right this conclud that concludes the
public speaking for this meeting now
councilor rattigan um I know you need to
leave but before you do um are there any
remaining items on the list that you
wish to reserve for debate thank
you I guess I guess not I'm just waiting
for to
go okay I will now call upon the clerk
to read out the remaining planning
applications if any member wishes to
reserve an application will they please
call out as the clerk reads thank you
thank you chair uh so we have
A35 Brad street
Ramsgate A6 60 North umland Avenue
Margate A7 12 the Bell Alliance Square
Ramsgate and A8 Margate Harbor arms
Stone Pier
Margate thank you thank you can I have a
proposal to move that the applicant
ations that have not been reserved be
determined in accordance with the
officer's
recommendations councilor Alban and
councelor
Rakin he out coun sorry you mean I think
R RI
sorry sorry do members
agree um do members
agree thank you very much um so for the
benefit of the public I will now call
upon the CL to read out the applications
that have been determined thank you
chair so that's A3 uh A35 Broad Street
Ramsgate A6 60 North umberland Avenue
Margate A7 12 the Bell Alliance Square
Ramsgate and 8 A8 Margate Harbor arms
Stone Pier Margate thank
you right thank you and uh for members
um of the committee just um an
additional item um Mr Livingstone has
something he wishes to say thank you
members I won't keep you very long it's
just hopefully you'll have received an
invite for some training at the end of
the month just please if you could
either if you haven't already accept it
or if there are issues and you can't
attend either those two sessions please
do let us know and we'll try and
accommodate uh as best as we can before
the Committees in December thank
you and just a reminder about the um
uh site visit will be at
9:30 on the whatever the firstc 1st of
dece Friday the 1st of December thank
you and that concludes the
meeting
[Music]
9:30
for